oh I'm pushed the wrong button
okay we good CLK no I don't care about
clerk you have something to write
on yeah I forgot that I could just write
that sheet okay all right okay we'll
open up the public
hearing
on 1406 and here from the prime sponsor
representative Reed good morning
representative
Reed good morning Mr chair and thank you
honorable members for welcoming to your
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent New Market and
newfields and um before you I have a
bill 1406 that would um effectively ban
the pricing of goods services on the
basis of gender you may have heard this
phenomenon called the pink tax um not to
be confused there's some confusion
because there's a lot of different ways
in which women spend more just to live
than men and sometimes um it's confused
with the idea that there in some states
not here obviously there's a tax on
menstrual products this is not that this
is literally pricing for example the
go-to example is Gillette makes a black
razor um it is black and silver and it
costs $4 the same exact razor in pink
costs seven that is gender based pricing
so this is a Barbie tax a Barbie tax if
you will yes um and there are two states
that have um passed similar
legislation uh this is drawn directly
from one of those uh functioning laws
that currently exist
so I've I've known about this phenomenon
for a while it was about a year ago that
um I kind of got up in arms over it
because I went to WR Aid to buy a small
pair of like manicure type scissors and
I was unwilling in the manicure area to
pay the $10 that the scissors were were
priced at and then I had the genius idea
knowing that this was a phenomenon to go
over to the men's section and wouldn't
you know not only a pair of scissors but
a much better quality pair of scissors
cost $4 instead of
$110 um and I was just so mad in that
moment I'm like I'm putting this in next
year I'm definitely doing it finally so
that's uh that's my personal story on
this so on average and this is a very
well-studied phenomenon on average uh
products that are identical in cost of
manufacture in ingredients and and in um
materials uh cost
7% higher when they are marketed to
women um for only the marketing process
whether it's the color of the packaging
or what have you um but that's average
on uh on the low end you have 4% but on
the high end you have as much as double
um or even more in some some particular
cases I've given you a handout where you
see a number of uh of examples my
favorite one by the way if you look at
the calculators you can't see but the
darker looking calculator has pink
buttons and you can see the price
differential there for the same exact
calculator that has pink buttons rather
than white
buttons so because of that it is
estimated now this is from 1994 data uh
women spend
$1,350 more per year to just exist than
men however that's $1
1994 uh in today's dollars it's closer
to $2,400 a year a woman and spends more
just to buy the same types of things
shampoo soap what have you this is by
the way not including actual sex based
products so for example things like
menstrual products or what have you this
that would not be gender based that
would be sex based because you're
actually using something that men would
never use but this is just the
difference in how it's marketed with all
other uh materials and cost being the
same um and what that $2,400 per year
means is that on the the adult
consumptive lifespan of the average
woman women are spending
$100,000 more just to live during their
consumptive adult
life so as I said two states have
already banned this pink tax this
gender-based pricing um the bill before
you repeatedly exempts anything that
doesn't have to do so if it's you know
you have to compare the cost of the the
actual manufacturer or the cost of the
service the time it gives um it takes to
give the service the difficulty of
service if it's a service uh the
ingredients everything um has to be
taken into consideration so that it is
only the gender that it's marketed too
that is the
difference and I guess I'll just kind of
like uh I don't think I have a lot of
opposition in the room other than the
AG's office who will tell you that this
will anytime you pass a law that makes
something illegal they have to
potentially do some more work but um and
I understand that but um the arguments
that I can foresee is well isn't this
the free market um and I
mean yes
but is it free when so the idea of the
free market is kind of oversimplified
because anybody who's taken more than
one economics class can tell you that it
doesn't just always boil down to supply
and demand but the idea is that those
are free forces that are able to
negotiate with each other freely but the
problem is when you have an industry
that sees that they can prevent any
other options from existing for the
demand side the demand side gets
hamstrung and they don't have any other
choices so for example and I hate to
bring up a triggering example but it's
it's probably the most recent and famous
example of price scouching um was during
covid when there were people who were
stockpiling toilet paper and stockpiling
hand sanitizer and then charging like
$50 for a bottle of hand sanitizer in
the beginning days of that so we kind of
universally agree that that's kind of
egregious Behavior but that in effect is
what these industries have been doing
across the board because it's it's
effective price fixing they know that if
they don't provide any uh lower cost or
more fairly um priced options that the
demand side has no choice but to pay for
those things so um I guess I'll open up
oh and the last piece of that is we do
regulate that type of behavior right we
do say that you can't discriminate on
the basis of sex or gender in commercial
activities like housing or employment
you can't discriminate on the basis of
sex or gender um for commercial public
amenities so I think that it makes sense
that we say actually if it's if it costs
you a dollar and you're charging $2 then
it shouldn't matter whether you're
selling to men or women I think that's
just kind of Common Sense and I'll take
questions represent representative M
you uh thank you Mr chairman um I
have I have two questions uh both very
very simple uh and not substantive but
um on um page two uh line
20 where it says different price for two
goods shouldn't that say two goods or
services um you are correct
representative and I'm happy if the
committee sees fit to want to work with
this bill and in in hopes of finding a a
version that passes I'm happy to work
with the committee to prepare that okay
uh the second one is a little harder um
oh I apologize representative I think
that no no you're right I was thinking
the previous section addressed uh
services but yes go ahead okay um uh and
that is um shouldn't this bill have an
appropriation
attached an appropriation for the the
Attorney General's office uh if you look
at the fiscal note it says uh does this
bill provide sufficient funding to cover
estimated expenditures and the answer is
no and then on the next page um there's
uh estimated costs for personnel um I
don't know that three people would
necessarily be needed um but uh I think
the the estimation certainly for for an
additional person is probably not
unreasonable um and therefore shouldn't
there be something to cover that so the
the three salaries given in that um as
it it stated was just an example of what
those salaries would be but the
department did not come back and say it
would cost them a specific you know
amount of extra labor hours so if the
department were to give us an idea of
how much extra they would want or just
even a ballpark to enforce it then yes
I'd be happy again to work with the
committee to amend it to put in
Appropriations for one extra staff
person I'm sure that the um uh
representative behind not repres
representative representative but the
person behind me that's from the AG's
office will uh speak more in depth to
that thank you representative M thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question of Reed um I often have my
razors stolen for that very reason um
but I I will ask you just this state
simple question
um can anyone buy any product from the
top or the bottom row freely without
restriction
now yes and you know I kind of
anticipated this question um and this
kind of touches on a much broader
subject that you know I I want to make
sure that we focus on this bill but what
you're really asking is what is gender
and gender is the set of no I wasn't
asking what is gend if you would allow
me to to let her go where she wants to
go the the thing is is that I'm here in
a skirt and makeup today as is as are
many of the women here because we grew
up in a society that told us that's how
we are expected to appear and present
ourselves and the gentlemen here are
wearing suits for the same reason and
with that societal pressure I mean I
personally would love to see a world
where that ended where there's no more
expectation placed on people for how
they appear for their characteristics
for their roles in society or aptitudes
based on their body parts that they were
born with however I'm not trying to go
after that larger concept cept I'm
saying that if we're going to have that
societal pressure and we're going to say
that people are expected to be to behave
a certain way then we can't say one half
of those people who have this
expectation have to pay
more further question me inquir thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking a
quick followup um it seems like it kind
of corrected itself in the toothbrush
Market I tend to stockpile toothbrushes
I like to have a few of them and the
doesn't matter what color they are
they're all about the same same price I
think I've currently got a you know
orange one and a purple one and
sometimes that confuses Julie she takes
the purple one thinks it's you know the
more Fe feminine color reminder that's
my toothbrush right at the moment right
so um you can say that as of this moment
tooth care is not a highly gendered
Market but it goes there like I said I I
gave you the example of the um the
calculators but I'm not sure if I
included the picture or not when I was
looking through all the pictures didn't
want to give you 50 pages of pictures
but
ducula has a blue box and a pink box
with the same ingredient the same dosage
of the ingredient and the pink box costs
more so I presume we all have the same
bowels and it's not you know affecting
us differently since it's the same
ingredient so it is very very pervasive
into Industries ands and products that
shouldn't really logically have anything
to do with gender and just because it
hasn't yet you know affected the
toothbrush Market doesn't mean it might
not one day I could imagine Barbie
toothbrushes and
whatnot okay we got lots of questions
Z thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking our question uh my wife wants me
to buy her a uh 6inch electric chainsaw
and she wants a she wants a pink one and
I told her uh let's think about it
because it's they're very dangerous
tools but the pink one is I think a few
dollars more than the regular one so
this is a conversation going on um but
you mentioned that certain uh certain
products that are different colors might
cost more and uh would you believe that
if it's a shorter run of production that
that would cost more because the scale
of the efficiency of scale isn't there
so like for instance if you price out a
car and you want a a special color from
the dealership they might charge you
another th000 because they not they're
not cranking those out regularly would
you believe that the market sort of
sometimes uh that's a market
determination because of the smaller
scale because of the smaller scale even
if that color has nothing necessarily to
do with gender marketing this bill
covers that so it says if it costs you
more to make then or it costs you more
to buy then you can't then it's fine you
can charge a different amount it's only
if it costs the same amount it's only if
the materials and the manufacturing
everything was the same that and the
gender marketing was different that that
was the differential that's that's what
this goes after specifically so that's
all Exempted no I did see that loophole
uh or excuse me that that exemption um
but having said that it seemed like a
potential loophole because now if the
Attorney General's office calls up and
say we think you you know charging
overcharging and now that Merchant or
the business the manufact is now going
to you know have to defend you know
lawyer up and and the lawyer says well
you know how many runs did you make of
this or that can't you didn't use that
as an excuse
so you really are just you're actually
discriminating against
pink you are implying that pink is a
feminine product as though no men would
want pink you are actually you are
actually that's why when I said Barbie
because that the whole point of
marketing is to appeal to the
consumer and so if the consumer a
woman prefers pink duux because that
means oh it it's it's okay for women
maybe I don't know why they think that
you're saying oh because they did that
that it you know they they should be
lawyer up and and they got to get try
you they got to you know they got to
change their pricing they got to do all
that when it really is a marketing issue
here's my problem there's a bunch of
points here I bought I bought a backpack
for my wife and I was looking for the
sale price well the only one that was on
green and they were out of them and said
and I said' well how what it's your
replacement well you have black but you
got to pay more for that
so companies are actually marketing that
price the color the color change
whatever is their choice it's their
marketing choice and it really I my
question to you is you are basically are
discriminating against the color pink
because is there any other color is
there any other shade that you think is
the word pink is not in the bill to be
very clear but you all agree everyone
agrees that pink is what you're going to
use for discrimination because if it
wasn't pink if there was a one product
was black and the other one is green and
it says and are you going to say is did
it save for women on the package if I
may be allowed to respond to some of
those multiple points so um maybe I'll
work I'll I'll try to work in in order
of the notes that I've taken here so
this idea that um well there was a
limited production of this thing so now
the AG's office is going after them I
think it's really clear um and it would
be a very simple you know two-minute
process for the AG's office to check
whether or not a particular company has
put out the same Gillette we'll say has
put out you know so many millions of of
razors marketed for women versus razors
marketed for men if it's a limited
production then again that's excluded in
the bill so that would be an easy like
well I guess we're not going to go after
them it's up to the asg's office whether
they go after someone if they think even
a claim of a limited production or an
increased cost of any kind um is you
know reasonable that they don't feel
like they want to go after and pursue
that line of arguing um so the idea that
I'm discriminating against pink in a
bill that's saying you have to price
things the same regardless of the color
how they're marketed so not regardless
of the color because that was also a bit
of a of a
misconception there's no like color
issue in this we call it the pink tax
and I think that's where we're getting
because it is frequently the color pink
or purple or whatever what's considered
feminine colors in a particular issue
but it's about is it marketed to a
particular gender and let me be very
very specific because you brought up
well what if a guy prefers the color
pink okay in fact there are makeup
companies now that have as their models
men wearing the makeup so it's really
not about sex it's about are you
marketing to a particular gender is it
feminine or is it masculine and I don't
mean like is it a product that only
women use I mean is it feminized or
masculinized in the marketing when every
other factor means that it has the same
cost of production that is what it's
getting to and if in a bill that's
saying you have to level that out I
don't understand the allegation that I
am discriminating against something I am
undiscriminating you more because we are
marketing it to
a the woman can buy the the man version
the way I read this bill that man
version has to be exactly the same as
the woman's version the only thing
different is the
packaging if that is true there is
nothing stopping a woman from buying
that package not and they're not going
to get charged more and because that is
why I'm saying you're discriminating
against the the fact that the package
might say for
women rather than for men what what
you're saying is that they need them
advertise that it's uh the men's version
or the cheaper version they need to say
on this for
everybody no they don't need to say for
everybody they have to not charge a
different amount it can still be
marketed towards women it just can't
cost more and by the way I don't didn't
hear a question in any of that but um so
I'm I'm worried this is turned into a
debate more than a hearing but having
said
that um I I don't going back to the
previous thing you're you're you're
saying that women I mean I answered this
question earlier women can buy like I
did with the scissors the masculine
product but we live in a society that we
say we expect as all of the women here
are wearing some feminine thing our
clothing it may cost the same amount to
make this shirt as your shirt and yet I
issue
okay represent uh Gibbs has already had
a question anybody had not
representative Herbert has not had a
question yet
um you said that two states have uh
passed this bill um I'd like to know
what the states are and uh get a sense
if you have any feedback coming from
those two states as to how the bill has
been effective or not effective I just
would like to know what happened in
those two states thank you very much um
at the risk of triggering some people
those two states are New York State and
California and all reports so far are
positive you can you can feel free to
look up just even just look up the words
pink tax um it's it there's a wealth of
information online and virtually no one
thinks that this is an okay
practice okay representative Gibbs thank
you Mr chair
uh this is a followup on some of the
questions uh asked by my colleagues um
and I'm sorry that the gentleman um on
that side uh has left the room because
that train of questions uh actually
started with his but um uh this is
essentially would you believe um that uh
while indeed um if the men's razor and
the women's razor are the same uh but
one is marked for men and one is marked
for women regardless the color uh I can
buy the men's if I want um but if I go
to the cleaners with a woman's Blazer I
have discovered that it costs more to
get the woman's Blazer clean than a
man's jacket and I do not have the
choice to turn my woman's Blazer into a
man's jacket I have to pay more for it
would you believe that I would
absolutely believe that and I would
further believe that women's haircuts
and you can't go into the the salon and
say that I'm not a woman unless you feel
like trying to you know change your
gender identity for the day um cost more
than men's haircuts for the same exact
cut even with short hair even with you
know the Simplicity of the cut um many
services Geared for women are charged
more for women than for men um I I when
I get a a manicure for example I always
they they mark at Men's manicures I
never want polish the only difference
between the men's manicure and the
women's manicure is the lack of Polish
in the men's manicure but I still get
charged for the women's manicure even
though I'm not getting polish and am
effectively getting the men's
manicure representative Amon has a
question I just have one last question
thank you for your good-natured
testimony today thank you here's my
question you you referenced uh the the
women on our committee today and and you
also said that gender is a social
construct how do you know which of us is
a woman on the on the committee I don't
know your biological sex I I can tell
from how people present themselves that
they are presenting themselves in a
feminine manner or a masculine Manner
and that is gender your biological sex
is none of my business um it should
really be only your business your sexual
partner's business and your doctor's
business further question you see where
this is going to go so when this is
where I was afraid like this is
literally not about that but okay I
guess we're going to have to go there
just a clarification when you say woman
do you mean biological sex or do you
mean gender for the purposes of this so
for the purposes of this bill this is
only the concept of feminine and
masculine not anything to do with
Biology and in fact as I already said if
it's something that you are biologically
using because you're a woman then that's
not in this bill because there's no
equal counterpart on the male side so
there's no such thing as the
gender-based pricing for example on
feminine products I mean by feminine
products I mean sanitation products uh
tampons and what have you because
there's no masculine version of
that representative
Walsh thank you Mr chairman uh this is
we'll have a question but it's also
would you believe being a biological
woman and planning on staying that way
uh I've noticed all of my life
everything that has said here thank you
that we always have to pay more and I in
total agreement with this Bill thank you
for writing it and that the fact that
yes it's a free market but not all women
are going to go and hunt and search and
Peck for down other aisles to see if
there's a a less expensive you know
marketed to men's version of whatever it
is they're looking for I mean when it's
easy when it's such as I think this is a
deodorant or whatever this is shamp I
think shampoo when they're right next to
each other yes it's F it's easy to see
the difference but that's also easy to
see that they're blatantly different and
charging more for the one that is
marketed towards women gray bottle
versus white bottle right so uh my
question would be if if this were to uh
be passed what type of enforcement is
there uh to this oh read the so so this
is she needs to put in a fiscal note no
no no the bill in front of you to be
fair you don't have to read the fiscal
note for the the enforcement is in the
bill the enforcement is in the bill and
this but again because the issue was
brought up can't a woman just go get the
masculine version what you are saying
therefore not sex but gender that women
in order to merely just pay the same
amount that men do in life must undergo
a process by which they change how they
express their gender in the world
because I have to buy masculine items I
have to buy masc if if the woman's
blouse and the skirt cost more than the
man's shirt and the the suit pants then
I have to buy those things instead of
those things uh because that's the only
way for me to you know pay the same as a
man is to dress like a man and buy men's
products that all of my razors have to
be black and all of my bottles have to
be black and and gray or what have you
so that's what you're saying is that
well if you want to save money then be
masculine by masculine products that's
that's no that's been the argument
consistently is that well can't a woman
go by from the men's aisle or from the
men's section and get the gray thing or
the thing without the pink isn't that
the case and my point is in a society
where we do enforce
gender then you are saying that a woman
has to present and by buying products
that are meant for men present uh more
in a masculine
fashion okay so um would you like to
hear a story that's very similar to this
legislation I I it's because I you I
heard you don't you only want a question
from me but Donna
Susi actually brought a
bill and and I talked to her about it it
was her very first term she was a House
member and brought it to this committee
and the issue was dry cleaner
and the issue was and she brought it
that the button- down shirt she brought
two man and woman and I didn't even know
this at the time but she said you can
tell the difference is because the
buttons go the other way correct but I
never knew that until that that hearing
and uh the goes back to equestrianism by
the way which I'm the bill died and the
the blur on the committee the committee
was cavior mtor which is yes the buyers
a woman needs to be
aware that just because the packaging is
is aimed towards them they don't have to
buy that more expensive product simply
to fit The Stereotype of that pink means
that they're supposed to buy pink that
they not have to be Barbie they could be
Ken and buy the black said what I said a
second ago you don't have to be Barbie
you can be Ken meaning I if I want to to
to to pay the same amount to live in
this world as a man have to buy
masculinized products which therefore
means to some degree as far as clothing
and other things that are visible my
products that I will have to present in
a more masculine form to the rest of the
world because I have been forced in
order to save the money to buy more
masculine items and what I'm saying is
if you don't want to challenge the IDE a
that we have gender if you want to
accept the fact that we have gender
norms and that people are expected to
present in a way that that you know
shows their gender then at the least you
can do is not penalize one gender when
they go to actually buy the products to
present themselves in that way and you
get the final word thank you very much
well thank
Brandon
red is on or red is off red is hot red
good good morning Mr chairperson members
of the committee my name is Brandon Gad
I'm a senior Assistant Attorney General
chief of the consumer protection and an
trust Bureau at the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office I'm here today
not to take a position one way or the
other on this bill but simply to point
out some concerns that the Attorney
General's office have um not only in the
fiscal impact but also in our ability to
enforce it and you know I'd just like to
take the time to point out that you know
the Attorney General is here often
testifying that a change in the law that
puts new responsibilities into the lap
of the AGS would necessitate additional
resources that does happen frequently
but it's not every time um we look very
carefully at every bill and we look at
what we anticipate the bill would
require us to do how much work it has
the potential to generate and whether we
could do that with the resources that we
currently have and if the answer is yes
you will not hear us over here saying
you know this is more work therefore we
need more resources and a great example
of that is the bill that's on following
this bill um which would add a new
requirement to the consumer protection
act I will not be here testifying on
that saying that it would have a fiscal
impact on the AG's office because I
don't think that it would um it's a very
careful analysis that is done on every
single bill to make sure that if we are
entrusted with a new responsibility that
we are able to do it both in the volume
and able to do it meaningfully so that a
responsibility that has been entrusted
to our office can be carried out
meaningfully and we can enforce that law
as it's written so with that context you
know the this specific Bill while you
know first of all I I just want to say
that you know as a general concept being
charged the same amount for the same
product regardless of your gender or
your race or anything else I would hope
is something that everybody can agree on
certainly something that you know the
Attorney General's office would strongly
support and you in this bill it has two
different you know tracks that we would
be enforcing one for goods and one for
services the comments that you're going
to hear from me today are almost
entirely geared towards the goods arm of
this bill because I think the
requirements as to services are largely
reasonable en forceable and could
potentially you know be handled you know
maybe with additional resources but
maybe even without it's really the goods
portion of this that you know is
problematic so you know and the reason I
say that is if you look at Services you
know the the example was raised uh
haircuts and dry cleaning if a salon is
offering you know a buzz cut cut and a
man wants a buzz cut and a woman woman
wants a buzz cut and they're charging
two different prices it is very easy for
us to go in investigate look at you know
exactly what the product or the service
that's being offered is and determine
that they are substantially the same and
say no you're charging the exact same
thing for the exact same service for two
different people because one is a man
and one is a woman and that violates
this law and we could take action to
enforce that that is doable and that is
enforcable you know as anticipated by
the statute I would imagine probably the
same with the dry cleaning example that
was given you know if two different
let's say a man's jacket and a woman's
blouse you know there's two different
prices to dry clean them to apply
certain chemicals wash them I don't know
how see my ignorance on how dry cleaning
works but you know if the service is
exactly the same and the price is
different you know we could do that
investigation we could make a
determination whether that service is
substantially similar you know for the
man's service and the woman's service
but I think it's very very difficult if
not impossible to do the same thing as
it you know pertains to goods and I'll
do my best to explain why but it's the
goods portion of this that you know
going back to resources and you know a
fiscal impact on
doj potentially what could happen if
this bill was you know signed into law
as written is that consumers across the
state could file a complaint with the
Attorney General's office for every
single type of product every single
brand of product every single type of
product where there is a man's version
and a woman's version and say the price
is different I want the Attorney
General's office to investigate that has
the potential for an enormous influx of
complaints into the Attorney General's
office which we would not be capable of
handling with the resources that we
currently have so that is why your
fiscal note that you saw in my testimony
here today um is specifically here about
the need for additional resources in
order to enforce this bill it's not just
that it would be more work it's that the
specific work that would be required to
handle what could be an enormous influx
of complaints is beyond the capabilities
of the resources that we currently have
and it's relatively impossible to
anticipate the number of complaints and
how many additional resources we would
need to do it um potentially a way to
determine that would be to inquire with
New York and California to see how it is
played out there but we simply don't
know at this time but in addition to the
the resources question you there are
concerns that I have as it pertains to
Goods in terms of our ability to enforce
this again not the intention behind the
bill because I think the intention is
good but I don't want and the Attorney
General's office doesn't want
responsibilities that it can't deliver
on it doesn't want to create an
expectation that you know we are going
to make sure that this law is upheld in
the state and then we don't have the
ability to do it because of the way it's
drafted and I think that's what you have
here on the goods portion um there is an
inherent complexity in determining
whether two goods are substantially
similar um and there are four factors
that are listed in this bill that we can
use to determine whether so not four I'm
sorry there's actually six factors um
the amount of time it took to
manufacture such Goods or provide such
services so again for services that's
easy we could figure that out but for
goods I mean if you use the two razor
blade examples the ability to figure out
how much manufacturing time went into a
specific razor is not something that is
easily done um we have certain
investigative techniques that we can use
we can issue subpoenas to company we can
ask them to tell us how much time um but
even if they respond and say it took
this many hours for this one and this
many hours for this one it's very
difficult if not impossible to verify
that that's truthful short of going to
their plant where they manufacture these
products and watching them do it and
determining that one took longer to
manufacture than the other one and that
same complexity and that same difficulty
applies throughout these number of
factors that we would be entrusted with
evaluating every every time a complaint
about a good was filed in order to
determine whether it was substantially
similar or not um the difficulty in
manufacturing such Goods or offering
such Services I mean difficulty is not
something that can be measurable in
response to a subpoena you know
difficulty speaks to difficulty what
amount of skill is required to do it you
know what type of machine is used how
complex is that machine how many people
does it take to run that machine you
know these are not the types of things
that we have the ability to meaningfully
and accurately investigate in order to
perform that analysis of whether two
goods truly are substantially similar or
not and I think that can be applied
almost across the board in the various
different areas where you have a men's
version and a women's version of a
product such as you know shampoos and
body washes clothing you know if two
different sweatshirts two different
pairs of shoes I think it's much bigger
than you know if you I guess what I'll
say is if you truly have a
scenario where the only difference in a
product is the color since we spent so
much sh on color you know perhaps that
example is easier and could be done but
that is not often the case I mean men's
razors look different than women's
razors sometimes they have more blades
one has more blades than the other
sometimes they have different qualities
of blades I think you know I I just
don't know and none of us know because
we're not expertise we don't have that
expertise in the industry so we would be
entrusted with answering that question
every single time that a consumer file a
complaint and it's wouldn't be as simple
as just you know all right somebody's
going to file a complaint against
Gillette and then we're going to look at
all of gillette's products you know
every single brand of Razor would could
be potentially investigated every single
model of each razor and that's just
razors I mean it's you know bicycles
calculators backpacks you know the the
materials that were provided give a
number of different examples and every
single one of these companies every
single one of these models um would be
fodder for investigation by the Attorney
General's office in order to determine
whether or not the two products if
priced differently are substantially
similar or not based on you know the
factors that are included in the statute
and I I just like to point out two other
you know concerns not necessarily
related to the substantially similar but
in reference to the relief that the AG's
office can bring and some clarifying
that I think would be helpful there if
the committee decides to move forward
with this um currently it anticipates
that we can get restitution through a
court if we find that you know two
products are being sold that are
substantially similar at different
prices um it's unclear as to how we
would go about determining the
appropriate number of is is rest so if I
mean one way that you could do it is it
would require determining every single
product of that type of product that was
sold in the state ordering the company
to pay the difference between the two
and then administering some sort of
restitution fund where the the Attorney
General's office is cutting checks to
every single person in the state that
bought one type of product and then
sending checks across the board I mean
that that really also goes to you know
the resources question and why we're
here testifying about this today and you
know finally Roman three under
enforcements speaks to um we can impose
a civil penalty not to exceed 250 for
each violation and then you know a
subsequent penalty for a subsequent
violation but the bill as written does
not provide any guidance as to how we
determine what amounts to a violation in
order to determine how we can find a
business you know is a violation each
product that is sold is a violation each
type or model of a product that is put
into the marketplace is a violation each
day that this product is out there or is
a violation something else you know
these are questions that we have to have
the answer to in order to be able to go
into a court and ask them for this type
of relief um and if
this does move forward I would strongly
encourage the committee to think very
carefully about defining what amounts to
a violation um so that the Attorney
General's office would have some clarity
in being able to enforce that provision
of the statute if it became necessary
happy to take any
questions okay representative
burrow yes thanks for taking my question
I I was thinking about your uh example
that might be easier with services and I
I mean I just thought of the buzz what
you suggested the buds buzz cut example
could actually be very different if a
woman has long hair to do a buzz cut I
would think it might take more time than
a male or if like I wanted to get my
legs waxed and representative Terry
wanted to get his legs waxed my guess is
his might take more time than mine I beg
your
pardon all right I'll use chairman hunt
as the example so you know I think that
that could be problematic too just in
terms of time and it would have to be
very carefully defined I think that
you're right and but I think what this
bill is seeking to guard against and it
does do a good job of this is
determining you know if in order to
determine whether services are
substantially similar those are the
exact type of factors that we could look
at and a business could say yeah here's
the justification you know this person
came in but you know the the the problem
with that is that there are women out
there that just have a buzz cut and you
know may want to maintain their buzzcut
and for that woman who wants to go and
just have her buzzcut maintain the same
way that a man does it may not take any
extra time so I think that is the
scenario that this is guarding against
and you know if this portion of the bill
that deals with Services were enacted
that's why I say you know under that
exact scenario where the services truly
are exactly the same there's no
additional time required we probably
that representative Bilo thank you this
is in regards to Services uh as well um
in a salon you have many um salons have
menus men's
women's a woman can go in and point at
the men's side and just say I want a
men's cut and I'm not sure what the
cosmetologist would do but if that
person wants a men's cut and it's listed
men's and women's they can point to I
want this men's cut or if you're going
in for a um uh manicure again I want a
men's manicure even if it's a female I
think you can ask that I'm not sure I'm
a cosmetologist so you can you can well
the question would be is if they have a
listed price right is that
discriminatory if someone a woman says
Okay I want that product that man's cut
isn't that discriminatory if they say no
you can't have it or we're going to have
to charge you more wouldn't that be
discrimination which is what the intent
of this legislation I think that it
certainly would
violate this
legislation if what you had is arbitrary
pricing for the exact same Services
determined only by the gender of the
person who's asking for the service well
the reason I say that is because to me I
I I look at the consumer protection act
is is to to make the consumer whole you
know to to you know the restitution is
yes it's true we have triple damages but
at the end of the day the the idea is to
get the Merchant or get to to not um not
uh discriminate or and so I'm looking at
the Discrimination aspect here and that
uh if if someone is is
overcharging okay simply because of
their sex um I guess would go to the
Human Rights Commission you could take
it but our consumer protection statute
doesn't have any language around that
the fact that you could not charge more
simply because of your sex I'm not sure
I agree with that and I think that you
know that that that is a point that I
overlooked and it's a good one to make
which is that our consumer protection
act currently Outlaws unfair or
deceptive Acts or practices and there's
a substantial body of case law that
defines what is a deceptive practice um
and it's pretty well defined and pretty
easy to spot you know saying something
is something when it's something else
you know saying something is endorsed by
someone when it isn't basically lying to
people in order to get them to buy
something they would otherwise wouldn't
buy but the unfairness prong is very
open to interpretation and basically
looks to you know is the practice
unconscionable is the practice you
know would it raise the eyebrow of
somebody in in the world of Commerce and
charging the exact same price for no
other arbitrary reason other than you
know the perceived gender of the person
requesting the service could that be an
unfair practice under the consumer
protection act absolutely okay so that's
my question is that if that is then I
think the issue that we all agree on is
that no no one should ever be charged
more because of their sex right but that
if if if that they can get that service
like service and at that same price so
you feel confident that the consumer
protection act would protect for that
situation or should we should we drop
another line in there to uh clarify
that I will not say that I feel
confident because unfairness is defi I
mean there's no clear way to define
unfairness other than when you see
something and you say we think this
practice is unfair you investigate it
you determine the purpose behind the
practice the impact of the practice and
you know whether the practice is
something that is so contrary to what's
acceptable in our society that it you
know it shocks the conscience and it's a
case by case analysis that has to be
done and is always dependent on the
specific facts of the specific practice
ice you're looking at so I absolutely
think I will say I am confident that
under the right circumstances if you had
a business that was charging different
amounts for the exact same services with
absolutely no other basis other than you
know gender race age anything else you
know some arbitrary you know thing like
that that had absolutely no bearing on
you know the cost of providing the
product or the service all the things
that that I I as the consumer protection
bureau chief would investigate that as
an unfair practice and whe whether a
court would ultimately agree or not I
can't so we're going to take this up in
subcommittee in u the first week of
February or so so it'll give you some
time to think that one through but that
you know in terms of you feel
comfortable because I think that is a
that's a the loose end here question
here um that that we would certainly
hope the consumer protection act would
protect a consumer from a merchant
saying no you can't have that price you
can't have that I mean again you know I
don't know that I'm going to be able to
you know think it over and be able to
provide a more clear answer because it
all depends on the circumstances okay
but in that like the perfect storm of
what is needed under this statute which
is identical service identical product
absolutely no difference other than
we're charging a woman more for this
than a man I think that is an unfair
practice and I would if that complaint
came into my office and my Bureau and I
looked at it I would invest perfect
representa you have another question and
I see we have some other hands here um
thank you for your testimony you you
mentioned
discrimination you mentioned
discrimination on the basis of
age could that be applied to say a
senior discount where uh someone over
the age of 55 is charged 20% less than
someone under the age of 55 would would
the consumer protection Clause apply to
that scenario on age
in that giving seniors a discount is an
unfair
practice yes that's what he say you you
mentioned you mentioned discrimination
on the basis of age and that's that I'm
just asking if that applies well I think
there's a difference
between charging people more for
something for no reason other than you
know I see where you're going yeah I
think that our society has commonly
accepted that you know seniors citizens
are entitled to discounts on things from
time to time and I do not think that is
an unfair practice to apply those and
this this is what I mean about you know
shocks the conscience you know under the
consumer protection act you have an
unfairness standard and you know whether
the practice shocks the conscience of
society is one of the key factors that
we look at to determine whether it
amounts to unfairness as anticipated by
that statute I think that as a society
we routinely and regularly you know give
senior citizens discounts on various
things with good reason so I do not
think that it would fit that definition
just one quick followup thank you Mr
chair uh how do you determine what
shocks the conscience of society how do
you make that determination just just
curious because this is a a bigger
discussion I think thank you it's Case
by case you know you look at the
practice you look at if the practice is
an outlier in the industry you know it's
completely contrary to what everyone
else is doing what you know people deem
acceptable um there's the standard that
has been adopted that you know it says
that the the actor practice you know is
sufficient has a sufficient level of
rascality that it would raise the
eyebrow of those that are familiar with
the world of Commerce so if people that
are familiar with the world of Commerce
look at a practice and say whoa that's
way out of line you know that's there's
no reason for that that's bad that's
predatory you know that's but it's a
squishy analysis there's no like one
factor that you can look at and say if
this then shocks the conscience it's a
caseby casee basis and that's why I say
I can't say I'm comfortable that you
know the consumer protection act would
cover this because it would depend on
the very specific facts of the practice
how long it would be going on for what
the basis was what the impact was the
exact specifics of what was going on all
those things are relevant to doing a
much bigger legal analysis of whether or
not it potentially violates our statute
okay so um I see seven hands and we're
already have again getting behind
ourselves so or would you be willing to
stay around so these reps who have more
questions should you would be able to
take them out in the hallway for us is
that like right now yeah like right now
otherwise you could call
him I think he should go back call
somebody in California and New York and
they have all the answers and then the
next comes here we wouldn't be he would
have the answers right talk into the
microphone please so the question the
question is being posed is that uh given
that we will be having a subcommittee in
early February is he willing to call
people in California and New York and
see how they address these issues but I
I don't to me it's pointless because
everybody's consumer every State's
consumer protection statute is separate
is different and ours is unique and this
is the man who's in charge of enforcing
our consumer protection statute so I
have full confidence that if ever
someone had a complaint or has a problem
and they call him up and he will respond
that and because he's actually got a
whole he got volunteer you still have
the volunteers that help that help out
and help people and that they can
address these these issues I'd be more
than happy to provide my contact
information if folks have questions they
can follow up with me I don't think it
would be meaningful to Simply call New
York and say hey how's it going New York
is a very different state than New
Hampshire um their attorney general's
office is significantly larger than ours
is and it is just not a fair comparison
um however you know I think one inquiry
that could potentially be helpful you
know if the resources were allocated to
us to enforce this would be to see
whether any enforcement actions have
been brought under the goods prong of
this in either New York or California
assuming that this legislation is
identical and whether there were any
issues okay okay all right is that okay
for those who want to keep asking more
questions and we're already behind well
I actually had a comment at the ex
director of The Human Rights Commission
that I thought might be helpful I think
you can you can do that in the
subcommittee I will the subcommittee
would be great to hear I will do that
okay Mr chairperson could you you
provide my contact information to the
committee if anybody has followup
questions best thing to do is that um if
you if you email and just say email
house Commerce with your information and
that will go to everybody in the
committee room what's the specific
at I'll figure it
out I'm sorry I appreciate you uh doing
this for me thank you no problem okay
thanks all right so I will I will close
the public hearing on
1406 I didn't read the blue sheet uh
there
and and since since we're there's
nothing on how about 1071 might as well
bring it over while we're at okay all
right we're g to Now open up uh the
public heing and House Bill 1071 the
right to repair certain educational
technology and do I
have the pink cards do you did you fill
out a pink card no you can do it later
later so I also have um an amendment to
pass
around
um yeah right so we've had a right to
repair type legislation in the past and
this is
somewhat similar
so okay go ahead so hi I'm uh Eric
gallager uh representative for maram
County District 20 um which is conquered
W 6 and I'm here to introduce HB 1071
relative to the right to repair sir and
educational technology so yeah you're
right that um I did actually have a
previous right to repair bill um earlier
this term um the main difference there
between them is um just what specific
type of product is focusing on um the
previous
one was more focused on uh home
appliances so stuff like blenders or
mixers or irons um close irons or stuff
like that and then this one's more
focused on um educational
technology so the specific motivating
case for this one um is for cases where
um where school districts have bought a
large number of Chromebooks and then
been unable to repair them because
Google won't
um refuses to repair them anymore and
also refuses to let um anyone else
repair them either um since apparently
doing so
would require information that they're
not willing to give out um so actually
um since having filed this bill um the
case where the court case where um
Google and um school districts were
fighting this out Court actually um got
settled and Google agreed to um allow
them allow these Chromebooks to be
repairable um but I still think having
the law on the
books is good anyways just in case they
later change their minds or in case
there's a problem with some other um
just in case there's a problem with some
other
educational technology provider refusing
to repair
stuff um so yeah the
um
and this will save School District's
money um since yeah if they can repair
their products they don't have to be
buying new ones as much and spending
taxpayers dollars on that um and so to
um address the amendment
um a bit um there was one little
drafting issue
um where um with the definition of
necessary software updates
um so
um yeah if you look at how it's
currently written um just it's a runon
sense with
um commas so necessary the existing text
necessary software updates means
security updates to patch exploits that
if left un addressed leave the user
vulnerable to cyber crime bu bug fixes
patches Corrections it sounds like those
last three bug fixes patches and
Corrections are the things being that
the users being left vulnerable to but
um it's not actually uh modifying that
um it goes with the security updates
from previously so um the amendment just
kind of clarifies that wording there um
by splitting it into a separate sentence
um and also just some um updates on the
state of other right to repair
legislation around the country um so
California has
passed um some of their right to repair
legislation um and I think that's kind
of an instructive case to look at um
because I remember getting questions
here at the previous hearing oh well
won't this be burdensome on the um
companies that have to comply with it
and that was the um that was the AR
argument that Apple was making at first
against California's law um but then
after looking for it some looking at it
some more they realized oh actually we
can comply with this and it'll be fine
and then um they ended up supporting it
in the end um so yeah I think that would
be the same case
here um if and so Minnesota's also
passed right to repair um and the FTC
has also been making taking steps
towards um
uh doing federal administrative rulle
making um about right to repair but um
having talked with uh some people in
contact with them they do say that it
would be also good to do this at the
state level as well um
just you know to kind of show that
there's momentum behind it and that
people actually want this um
so yeah
um that's HB 1071 uh I'll take questions
now
great any questions from committee
members representative
Gibbs thank you um uh representative
Gallagher um in the original bill um and
in the amendment um uh I'm looking at
the amendment uh this is line three uh
it refers to security updates used to
patch
exploits um and I I'm not sure that that
exploits is is really the word that
should be there um maybe errors I I'm
not sure what no exploits is the correct
word that's the term of Art in the um
computer security word for world for um
vulnerabilities that uh an attacker
could potentially take advantage of it
it is a term of art yeah I'll take your
word for it thank
you okay any other questions from the
committee members seeing none thank you
very much all right um thanks I have one
other card here Chris Gil
techet representative G you you will
fill out a card right yeah okay great go
ahead thank
you oh yeah you
gotta better uh my name is Chris gilrain
I represent TechNet in the Northeast
TechNet is a trade Association uh
comprised of over a 100 companies in the
innovation economy uh here in opposition
to age 1071 uh techet member companies
uh that do manufacture technology like
this uh strive to offer a broad network
of trained authorized repair Outlets uh
for technology like this to be repaired
uh these are complex systems uh that
also tend to house a significant amount
of personal data uh so in this case it
would be you know student teacher School
District data uh on on these uh devices
using authorized repair channels uh make
has uh accountability both for the
safety of the repair particularly when
we're talking about things like lithium
I ion batteries as well as the security
of the data that is housed on those
devices uh for those reasons uh we
oppose h171 uh as it uh does not include
uh necessary protections for that data
or uh necessary training for the people
who would be uh doing these repairs
appreciate your time and happy to take
any questions um our written testimony I
believe was submitted um we are a
signatory onto a group letter yeah from
on right
Coalition okay any questions from the
committee members seeing none we thank
you very much for coming up here and
thank you very much no is there anyone
else who would like to testify on House
Bill
1071 only
suspense
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
House Bill 1624 here from representative
Wallace good morning representative
Wallace good morning chairman hunt
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me to introduce house pill 1624
for the record my name is scw Wallace
rocking County District 8 the town of
Danville uh once again I'm introducing
my bill that would remove the proabition
in New Hampshire on the uh home
distillation of spirits as you're all
probably aware we just became legally
able to make our own wine and beer here
in the state in 2012 or 13 Even though
the craft brewing Act was signed into
law by President coder in
1978 um as we all know the Liquor
Commission has a Kung Fu grip on all
things things liquor uh and as such
without that uh permission slip from The
Liquor Commission you can't do anything
related to that uh that being said we
did get successfully the ability to brew
wine and beer uh about a decade ago and
this is just the natural um evolution of
the hobby if you will um my bill would
allow uh those of us that Brew wine and
beer at home um in the particular
quantities that were allowed to 100
gallons maximum per household with a
single individual insid household or up
to 200 gallons of wine or beer um with
two or more individuals in that
household only that amount of wine or
beer also known as wash or Mash in the
trade uh could be used to produce
alcohol which would give you roughly a
10% yield so maybe somewhere between you
know 10 to 20 gallons as a function of
your household side and how ambitious
you might be in the in the pursuit of
this um the bill has been amended a
couple of times over the years and as
introduced this is how the bill was
amended most
recently um currently there are nine
states um that allow home desolation of
spirits uh some of our neighbors
including Maine Massachusetts and Rhode
Island most nearby others are spread
throughout the country Alaska uh Arizona
in Iowa and Indiana I believe in
Missouri was the first um historically
uh we've had an issue getting it out of
committee uh on the basis that this is
not lawful federally um well that
doesn't seem to matter in these nine
other states they've moved this forward
and um New Hampshire does have a
tradition of doing things on our own
despite what the federal Regulators or
our federal overlords might say um if we
consider we've got um medical marijuana
program here in the state already um
this very committee has several bills
that they're considering moving forward
that would um legalize cannabis
recreationally despite the federal
prohibition on that activity and also
Firearms we were we're at 2A Sanctuary
State as of last bium so we won't um
under the color of law help to enforce
any federal firearms laws promulgated
after uh one January 20th 2021 at this
point in time
so I think that that uh that argument
that we shouldn't move this forward
based on it being uh unlawful federally
is that's probably in the riew mayor at
this point
um interestingly uh there was a a
lawsuit filed in um the end of December
of last year uh out of Tampa district
court or Tampa federal court excuse me I
haven't read the pleadings yet it's it's
very new but this lawsuit argues that um
the prohibition on hobby distillation at
the federal level is in uh is
unconstitutional based on the repeal of
olet act which was Prohibition as you
know so it'll be very interesting to see
how that lawsuit moves forward and what
the outcome of
of it is um additionally going back
eight years ago when I first introduced
this bill um we've had a little bit of
movement at The Liquor Commission
initially they weren't all on board and
I think they've moved to kind of a
neutral position at this point um I
expect they'll be uh testifying behind
me to their actual position so don't
take my word for it um so that's where
we're at at this point in time this is a
uh an upand cominging activity for the
for the home distillers and um we're
making progress throughout the country
and um I'm asking that you would uh
support us in this endeavor I'd be happy
to take any questions okay so I I have
the the most straightforward question
yes sir have you ever applied for a
federal license
no do you know therefore you have no
idea what a federal license would cost
we've looked into it it's uh in order to
do this even the smallest federal
license is about a $1,600 that's not
what I
heard so why don't you do a little
investigated work and find out what
exactly the federal government is
requiring so that maybe we could pass a
law that says that youve got if you got
your federal license you can absolutely
home still you're missing the point
chairman hunt the point of the bill is
to remove the state prohibition the
federal government has already granted
us authority to make the alcohol alcohol
as you know is produced during the
fermentation process which is already
lost
in all 50 states and territories so the
act of distilling is merely
concentrating the already lawful
production of alcohol that is that
occurs at the fermentation process we
have a chicken or yeg problem
here clearly the federal government has
a law whether they enforce it or
not it's not you know
we're the end of the day they expect us
to enforce their
laws and all I'm saying to you is what I
want to know is what it would cost for
you as an individual to get a
license it doesn't cost anything to get
a license to make beer or wine because
it doesn't exist and that is the point
at which alcohol which is the key
ingredient is created and the creation
is the issue fair enough okay
additionally i' I'd turn that around and
say what are you even taking up cannabis
for in this committee it's not legal
federally so
we absolutely the commission as a member
of that commission what it was made
clear to us is that at this
point and it could change the Attorney
General's office the federal attorney
general's office does not allocate any
money for enforcement of marijuana
statute and so therefore that is the
reason why states are able to go ahead
and do it but at any moment
at any moment a drop of a hat the
Attorney General might decide that they
do want to prosecute and then there
would be a problem across the country it
sure would but what I've heard lately is
that President Biden has uh there is
already a proposal to remove moove it
from schedule one to schedule three
correct and this there's been a um an
Unwritten shall we say non- enforcement
of the of the home distillers
Moonshiners that's a completely
different subject matter and a
completely different scale and uh that's
for the purpose of Revenue production um
but this is not if you want to use that
analogy about the
marijuana I have no idea where the
Attorney General's has any money or the
or the DEA has any money to go enforce
the home distilling
statute theoretically if they're
not there's nothing stopping anybody to
home
distill I can assure you are liqu
commission is not out there looking for
anybody they're not trying to enforce
anything unless somebody drops a you
know a dime on them so if you want to
use the marijuana analogy I say you
should go ahead and just keep home
distilling because nobody's going to
enforce
it but but the fact remains that they
could so that's why we're here to do
this the right way well I'm say all
those states have passed it have all
said with a caveat that just by the way
it's not legal
correct
okay we have a representative
representative mcve how are you sir good
good lot of shoveling this morning okay
um a question yes I'm a little confused
here but I think you might have
inadvertently answered my question
you're only talking about distilling
from wine and beer is that because you
don't need a license to do that so this
doesn't include include grains and corn
and anything like that no actually uh
wine beer mash and wash they're all
synon they're all the same yes I mean
beer is often made from grains uh not
just uh barley and and hops or rice wine
is typically made from grapes uh but
sometimes fruit um so anything that you
can ferment can be distilled so you
could use sorghum you could use you know
strawberries bananas coconut anything
anything with a sugar in it or a starch
can be fermented and produce alcohol
quick follow F question you you you
could make bourbon you could make Jin
you could make vodka you can make all
those things correct okay thank you very
much sorry melair sorry
sorry okay haven't seen you so long I
gave the wrong name to you okay all
post would would would you believe that
I believe it was in 2022 I passed a bill
Liquors we did file it last year this is
fourth or fifth time around at this
point it pass you may have voted for it
but it was it did pass no we we we have
not passed it because we didn't want to
send the false impression to anyone that
that it was actually legal to do it if
you go past it if we stay pass it and
the Govern Governor signs it everybody
oh well we can go out and do it and then
when the feds show up or some you know
get S gets enforced or someone drops a
dime and all of a sudden you've got you
know the ATF not the DEA the ATF
visiting you you might want to blame the
Hamshire legislature for passing
it any other okay did so you're all said
okay and representative
Ammon thank you representative for
taking our questions of course and and
full disclosure I'm a co-sponsor on this
so um are you allowed to ask questions
uh I think I can ask questions or
testify I can't do both correct it's
fine just not both um you gave the uh
the uh example of us being a second
amendment Sanctuary State could could we
do something similar with with liquor
enforcement that uh you know the the
state resources wouldn't be used to
enforce Federal home home distilling uh
enforcement
it um it sounds like a potential
Amendment representative Ammon that's
what he's saying yes I don't see why we
couldn't
okay okay anything basically uh if I
understand it correctly is we would pass
a statute that would say that the Liquor
Commission would not enforce the
statute which would be a similar
position to the state of Iowa it's they
don't specifically that's what they did
they've taken a position that they
haven't said it's okay but they're they
they also they're not going to uhfor say
that it's unlawful they're neutral on it
do what you want all
right thank you very
much I have one other card here
representative canton's from comp
sorry good morning Mr chair and thank
you members of the committee um I'm here
to support I'm also a co-sponsor on this
bill and I'm coming at it from a kind of
a different angle um we've been toying
around with the idea of buying a
still um for experimentation purposes
because I have a farm and I grow
specialty
berries um but Stills are kind of
expensive uh you you know in the scheme
of things uh especially if you're not
sure about the legality of it and I've
heard here said that it won't be
enforced but if you're going to drop you
know $1 to $5,000 on a still you want to
make sure that that's not money thrown
out the
window um we're growing a specialty crop
that is used for gin in around the world
and we would like the chance to
experiment with
recipes however because we don't have
hobby distillation being
legal I am not willing to risk my farm
for
that and I think it's really
important that as a farmer that we have
different Outlets to for value added
products and this would be a value added
product for
farms and to experiment with recipes
before spending the money um for
licensing to see if this is viable Etc I
think is extremely important
uh and the other thing is is that there
are a lot of universities online and in
person that are available to people to
learn about
Distillery and
Distilling
[Music]
um and as my former colleague said this
is
important Massachusetts and Maine have
both passed laws similar to this where
it is legal to distill alcohol in those
two
states and to say
that we can't pass this law because it's
not legal federally we do this all the
Hampshire so I would urge this committee
to seriously consider passing this
law because there's some of us that want
to do it the right way and we don't want
to go through the licensing and we don't
want to spend the money for a still
unless we can do it because it is state
law and I'm open for
questions I don't understand you're
getting a Distillery or you you can't
sell it I don't want to sell it but we
want to experiment with recipes on our
own before we decide if this is an
Avenue we'd like to really go delve into
and then then sell it and then we would
then we would have to apply for the
licenses and everything else
federally but if we can't but we have to
have a still
first and evidently I'm you can easily
get you can buy one from Amazon well you
can get them there is a Still Company in
New Hampshire yes but to make it legal I
can't make it
legally got
it okay any questions from the committee
members thank you very much thank you uh
Chief are you willing to uh come over
you and we have a
deputy yes who is
a thank you has a legal background
so so he brought his
counsel uh thank you chairman uh for the
record my name is Mark armaganian I'm
the chief of enforcement for the Liquor
Commission with me here today is
Danielle ston our deputy chief um as as
we were with the original version of
this bill we are neutral on it um but
we're here to take any questions that
you may have so what exactly does our
statute said do we actually statutorily
say no distilling or we just never
allowed it we just never we didn't put
it into what is
allowable correct it there is no I don't
believe the language specific speically
says no
distilling it says if you going to the
the statue only allows for beer and wine
and then if you're going to um sell or
make it you need the license to do so a
license to do so but we don't have a
license that allows it so is it possible
that how I mean I guess you can't answer
this question you obviously you have to
take it back to the chairman but that if
we were to pass a statute that says that
regulation I would hope that there's a
better way to get there uh Mr chairman
because I would not want to have to
change our position on our enforcement
ability so if there was another Avenue
to get there I I would definitely be
open to those oh good so you you'll go
way uh I'd like to talk to the
representative uh who who brought up the
issue of an amendment just to see what
the ideas are behind it right it's
just I I guess I don't know do we do
this know this second Amendment you say
that we have some oh yeah
so for yes I think it was House Bill
uh last year or this year it was two
years ago two years ago yeah and that uh
it it's specifically said that the state
will not use our resources to assist the
federal government in enforcing Second
us do you know what statute that
specifically fell under I could look it
up
that
all right anybody have any questions for
yes represent
yeah that bill 1178 says that uh we
won't help the feds and uh right we will
not facilitate that doesn't mean the
feds can't come in and do something that
is true so I don't know how that's going
to help in this case well it's like I
say learn with in the marijuana
commission is is that it's basically
it's it's allocation of resources yeah
no I understand so if the ATF says that
we're not going to we're not going to go
out and and uh chase down people right
uh uh unless you know unless they L I
think what I would think is that they'll
chase you down if they think you're
selling it if you're trying to sell
which is CH that's but yeah okay go
ahead so I just it's a RSA 159 d
[Music]
e well that's what we like to do here in
Commerce is find solutions that we can
with okay and
uh Peary first you know early
February awesome thank you all right any
other questions from the committee
members seeing n and fill out a card for
me please thank you okay with that uh is
anybody else would like to
testify no one else seeing none we will
close the
hearing
there
for
okay uh what are we doing we're doing uh
relative to liquor stores 11
98 thank you very much so today dealing
with a somewhat simpler topic and I'm
actually in favor I don't think I've
ever seen you so often in our community
I know it's like probably more than I
needed to do but I've had a good time
anyway so it's always always fun over
here at least at least if you're a
visitor and you did do a card right I
are
all right course now you have now you R
grass SE so we very good-looking guy we
look I think we look a little alike so
white hair the square head but right I
don't know he he has a better haircut
than you did oh he does yes okay so
anyways yes so I'm still represent
Timothy Oregon I continue to represent
straford County District 10 which is the
towns of just the town of Durham and uh
actually we actually don't have a state
liquor store yet you have to go to Lee
or do to uh get to partake of their
products but um we still we still like
the State Liquor Commission and Durham
too so I'm uh and this is a repeat of an
early bill from 2022 and
actually actually Mr chairman you and
the committee were helpful to me because
the thing I came up with was much more
complicated had some uh and you boiled
it down to like the most interesting
part of it so it's now it's pretty
simple and it actually came very close
it sailed to the house without much
trouble and then it came it it went
halfway to the Senate but they sent it
around the finance who then uh didn't
see the wisdom of it but maybe they'll
like hopefully they'll feel differently
about it this time so um so is it just
the way we sent it exactly exactly yes
well then it's dead on the Senate why
would we do that again um I ironically
it was the finance committee and
actually there's no the financial part
of it was actually like unimpeachable
was more on the principle of it and what
the principle of it is is that well
right now the liquor stores keep stores
on Main routs where traffic is heavy
open on Sunday or any legal holiday but
there's three exceptions which is Easter
Thanksgiving and Christmas and so uh
Thanksgiving Christmas are defined in
existing law there's actually Easter is
actually not a legal holiday and there
isn't really I isn't really any simple
way to define it in in the in the law
books it moves around from year to year
and actually different religious groups
observe it on different Sundays because
has to do with with uh it's the first
Sunday after the Spring Equinox but
there's various opinions about how
whether how to calculate that so that's
why it moves around a lot there's also
the Jewish fees of Passover which is
basically the same holiday and that's
actually fixed on a exact date in the
Hebrew calendar but that but then they
the Hebrew calendar keeps up with the
fact keeps up with the fact that like
there aren't there
365.25 days in year rather than 360 by
every so often adding a whole whole
extra month but that's I've already gone
off into the um ibly should have just
read my um testimony out out loud so
it's a simple piece of enabling
legislation doesn't require these stores
to be open on those three days it just
gives the commission the option of uh
ordering they're free to keep them
closed instead and full-time employees
be guaranteed at least one and a half
times the regular pay and all other work
rules will still apply and it's a uh
it's a it's a union Shop with a very
strong union but has a good ation with
the Liquor Commission so I'm sure that
part of it will be uh that part of be
that part of it will be worked out and
the purpose is simply to better serve
the public by giving them more
opportunity to buy wine and spirits on
those three days and to enjoy them
responsibly I was mostly thinking of
Travelers who need to pick up a few
bottles for responsible enjoyment at
their holiday gett togethers though may
also be useful for restaurants and
Caterers who are open on one of those
three holidays and I think um the fiscal
note um as it did last time
demonstration Liquor Commission will um
i' say certainly almost certainly make
more money if HP 1198 passes so the
sales in Easter Sunday it's fair to
assume they'll probably be similar to
any other Sunday in in March or April
and those uh apparently average about a
million dollars in gross sales and then
the uh labor cost which is the main cost
of opening the store and the date was
closed would amount to about 53,000 so
um so it looks like they would make
about uh
$947,000 if they're open on Easter
Sunday I they may cannibalize some sales
from earlier earlier in the season but
probably it'll be about the same
Thanksgiving Christmas a little bit
harder to hard of dict that is their
busy season the fiscal note describes
the sales as robust and if you've ever
visited one of our excellent stores of
which we're all a uh all like basic all
of us are citizens New Hampshire are
essentially shareholders in US those
stores are indeed very busy right before
Thanksgiving and Christmas I and I enjoy
going there but right before
Thanksgiving Christmas and getting some
bottles of New Hampshire made wine to
bring down to relatives in Massachusetts
um but the break even point for opening
of those two days is about 5.3% of the
uh regular of the uh of the of the
regular sales I'm sure the sales will be
more than 5.3% of what they would be on
a regular day and as I said once again
it's just enabling legislation so no
stores that aren't they're closed now
they only have to they can only have to
open it's just a business decision they
can make if if if they feel it's
worthwhile opening the store on those
days which I from a business standpoint
I believe it would be so that basically
uh is my bill I made it it's probably
even simpler than I made it sounds um
and oh believe me you don't want to try
to Define Eastern law I did that two
years ago and it was just a nightmare
unfortunately and fortunately if we pass
this bill there's only one reference to
Easter left in all of the rsas and
that's to a celebration called C our
Mother's Day which is the Sunday after
Easter and the governor will still be
able to sign a proclamation celebrating
that regardless of whether we pass this
because because um because what it what
it actually does we're just crossing out
one sentence from the RSA about when the
liquor stores can be open so I may happy
questions representative buo yeah thank
you for taking my
question why are you bringing this bill
forward how how would it affect the
state residents yourself I just don't
get it well I had the original version
of my bill had a couple of other issues
in it but those were not worth pursuing
this time so it's just uh I just feel
it's a worthwhile to have some of these
Outlets open I mean even aside from uh
buying their excellent products there
they're also like uh they also always
have clean restrooms they've also uh
they also now have vehicle charging
stations which the back of many which I
guess is more an initiative of the
landlords so there's I just think it's
worthwhile having them open especially
the we have two and I guess they're
planning to build more that are at rest
areas too and the rest areas are open
anyway so we may as well have uh you
know this part of the rest area open too
for those people who for whatever reason
good or bad find themselves traveling on
the holiday I know I know I quite
frequently find myself driving down
there on especially on Thanksgiving day
to visit relatives um on the other side
thanks okay any other questions from the
committee members yeah thank you very
much I'll just say Mr chair this version
of the bill is much better than my
original one from two years ago but
that's thank you that's because we did
it
thanks that was my point thanks but it
deal still died in the
Senate my advice to you is is that when
a bill dies in the first year of a year
session don't bother bringing back in
the second year just you got to wait
till some people
changed in that other body and then
bring it back this coming back every
year then then well this was in the
second year of the previous by any and
now it's the second year of this one so
I let it rest for same people on the
Senate side well it's the same let me
put it this way it's the same chairman
of the Commerce Committee who didn't
like it the last time yes and I don't
think he's going to change his opinion
this time Al the one Senate no chairman
the Senate side chair Senate Commerce on
the on the other hand no I'm the one who
wrote the amendment what are you talking
about and also on the other hand the one
Republican who stuck with the bill the
second time around is now the president
of the Senate so you never know but
thanks
okay yeah anybody else wants to testify
on this
issue see none we will John
question uh why do you not like it
what's that why do you not like it I
didn't say I didn't like it I cuz I
wrote this amendment I wrote this stat
I'm the one who I said the Senate
chairman of Commerce I didn't hear that
thank you Senate chair
yeah was the one who doesn't like
it so
yeah
scheduling on time okay up to public
heuring and House Bill
1621 and here from the prime sponsor uh
David
pre
good afternoon
goodno good afternoon Mr chairman uh
thank you I'm not the prime sponsor but
I'm one of the sponsors and I'm very
happy to be here I'm uh David priest uh
representative
of of District 17 in Hillsboro County in
Manchester and I'm here to speak in
support of HB
1621 to distribute posters and brochures
and other information to liquor stores
about alcohol use
disorder to start off with excessive
alcohol consumption is the third leading
preventable cause of death in the United
States on the average
79,000 people
die and 2.3 million years of potential
life years are lost each
year excessive alcohol consumption is
also associated with multiple Health and
Social
consequences increased Health Care
criminal justice cost and loss worker
productivity in the form of missed work
diminished output and reduced earning
potential now let's take this to New
Hampshire the 2012 report by poon
research
documented that excessive alcohol
consumption costs New Hampshire more
than
$1.15 billion do annually in l
productivity and
earnings increased expenditures for
health care and Public Safety
cost this
1.15 billion
represents
2% of the state's total personal
income not included in this total is an
an additional two
28.6 million in discounted lifetime
earnings lost each year by almost 300
individuals who die
prematurely each year in New
Hampshire as the result of excessive
alcoholic
assumption the state and local
1.15 billion in cost of excessive
alcohol assumption
is estimated to be
$251 million a
year in a recent
2022 report by the Robert Wood Johnson
foundation and the University of
Wisconsin New Hampshire has the highest
alcohol
assumption per capital of
New Hampshire consumption rate is almost
double the goal set for the United
States over 21% of the New Hampshire
adults drink
excessively and
33.1% of the driving
alcohol my rep my fellow represent
New Hampshire has a
problem we have a serious
problem HB
1621 is one way to address this by
reaching out to the public and educating
them on alcoholic abuse as well as what
resources are exist in their community
that can help them
I thank you for uh this opportunity to
speak I will answer your questions and I
do have a written statement to be
or you take questions yes I will okay
representative thank you thank you Mr
chairman I'll start um I didn't catch
the source of the data the where you
said 21% of all New Hampshire
adults uh drink excessively so I'd love
to know that that was with the Robert
Wood Johnson foundation and the
University of Wisconsin was a special
report that was
prepared thanks so my further question
um there's a lot of places you can get
alcohol like in a restaurant or a bar I
understand yeah so I don't actually know
I bet someone here does know know the
breakdown of you know what percentage of
alcohol is purchased in State Stores
versus
lenses so why why why just do this in
the liquor stores especially when many
of those customers are repeat customers
they're going to get the same brochure
or you know once a month or twice a week
or whatever they do and throw it away
well however they decide to distribute
the brochure is one thing and I think
the intent of this was to try to start
with the um state liquor stores and if
that was effective we could move on but
at I think that was the intent was just
to start with what we
could
control what can I ask one more question
thank you so you said if that's
effective we'd move on how will how we
know I don't know that for sure it's
effective yeah I don't know how if we
would move on if this was the intent but
I think this is a good start to
accomplish what we're trying to aim and
that is to educate the public that
alcohol is a disease it's toxic to one's
death
representative
pusk uh thank you Mr chairman I notice
on the hand out uh in 2022 the Robert
Wood Johnson Foundation found that New
Hampshire had the highest consumption
per capita of 4.6 gallons is this based
on uh product sold yes okay realizing
that probably half of the alcohol sold
in the state of New Hampshire is to
Residents outside of the State of New
Hampshire
um it could be I I don't know I don't
know what how they came up with this
number but it is alarmingly high when
you consider the other states follow up
further question being inquire thank you
Mr chair uh I know for a fact that uh
two of the uh State stores on Interstate
93 typically have no less than a half a
dozen vehicles uh Panel trucks vans with
out ofate license plates and they are
loading them up with trolleys of liquor
to go out of state and be sold at uh
some other
place you would you believe oh I would
believe that I see that all the time as
I'm driving two and fourth from
conquered and I see the license
place um I understand that and if we can
educate the outer Staters that's great
too but we've got to start with the
people of New Hampshire and see if we
can bring this rate down and the number
of
debts representative Gibbs thank you um
and thank you for your testimony uh
considering the uh fiscal note on this
bill shouldn't this bill have an
appropriation
attached yes and it will probably go to
the fiscal committee
afterwards I'm sorry I didn't hear that
probably we'll go to the uh finance
committee for a fiscal note and to
determine what amount of money should
would be spent to do thank you should I
don't have my copy it should say on the
yes
right sorry so that the finance
committee would deal with attaching the
appropriation thank
you okay uh well actually representative
walls just hasn't asked a question
yet uh just a another Point uh following
up with representative p
I live alone and when I go to the state
Lor store I might buy a few bottles of
wine that doesn't mean I'm going to
consume those bottles of wine it could
take me a year to consume those or I
might be buying them as gifts for others
so I think you know to his point in mine
that that's not considered as part of
this it makes you know this kind of
makes New Hampshire sound like we really
have a huge problem when I don't think
it's that we do have a big problem I
don't know if it's that big a problem
but we do have a problem okay all right
thank
you representative uh M
first thank thank you Mr chairman I just
want to go down the road of things that
are harmful and are likely to cause your
death sooner than your natural death
like alcohol there's also smoking heart
disease is a number one killer should we
put a pamphlet in with every bagged up
McDonald's fast food order because
that's statistically way more likely in
terms of heart disease to kill you and I
don't actually also don't think your
your data is reliable as we pointed out
well okay I I I think it is so guess
we'll have to disagree on that but
McDonald's is saying McDonald's is doing
their part by on their menu saying how
much fat content is in their products
right that's a good step and an
indication
um and I think other
responsible restaurants the tobacco
industry has a label on their packages
now I don't know if people re seiz that
but I know that they have put an effort
to reduce and to educate the public on
deaths from
tobacco and I don't think we're doing
that for alcohol excessive alcohol
consumption fair enough yeah we we
actually well it is required on alcohol
yeah the preg you know pregnant women
and then yes yeah it's those
alcohol so now representa
bil thank you it's just a comment I'm
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill and I
think it's a great start um I think
there is a huge problem in the state
with alcoholism and if we can do any
anything to educate people
regarding
the excessive um use of alcohol I think
the Liquor
Commission and other concerned citizens
could come together and find a way to
place something in the liquor stores um
to
educate just like cigarette companies do
I agree I agree yeah
representative post do you have a
question yes um would would you be aware
that um since 1989 in the United States
warning label labels on alcoholic
beverages are currently required to warn
of the risk of drinking and driving
operating Machinery drinking while
pregnant and other General health risks
including cancer and colon
cancer that's already on the bottles yes
but I guess is not working in New hampsh
so I think a poster in a good strategic
place of saying this is a this is a
problem this is a disease and by
consuming it you risk your
lives um you and a possible early
death but thank you for bringing that
up
followup so a person who knows that this
is not good for them because I think
most adults do and I think even uh young
adults do um what would make them have
that effect on them just seeing a poster
if they already know that language is
they know that it can be harmful to
their lives I I think it's just
the the view of the poster and the
marketing of the poster if it's
strategic it will it will cut to your
heart and you'll say h maybe I have a
problem and maybe I should look in to
myself and I think that is you know for
the bang of the buck it's it's worth
seeing something that applies to you and
if you stop to think about it and you
say yes I do have a problem yes I may
only have a glass of wine or two glasses
of wine and night but if that's every
night then I have a problem I'm addicted
to
expectancy okay represent
Burrows thank you for taking my question
I'm going to say would you believe that
um whenever I go to a medical
appointment um there are posters in the
bathrooms in the in the in the um in the
exam rooms that say you know if you're a
victim of domestic or sexual violence
here's where you go for help so and I
think those are incredibly effective and
I think given that this may have a phone
number or a place you can go this could
also potentially help people yeah yeah I
okay okay thank you very much okay thank
Aid okay would you like to offer up
something
okay
he so I I missed this this is
24 good day my name is Aiden Moore I'm
the legal coordinator for the State
Liquor Commission and uh we're not
opposed or supporting the bill we're
here I'm just here to see if I can
answer any any questions uh when this
bill was originally introduced I
contacted the sponsor I contacted the
sponsor um to try to figure out what it
is that he was looking for in in his
process and I think what we talked about
largely was based on what information do
you want to get out and how how would
you want it to to to be disseminated and
as a part of that um we talked about
posters we talked about Flyers we talked
about a number of things and as you can
see by our fiscal note each of those um
comes with a bit of a cost which is not
in our budget um I talked to graphic
Services about a single page
three-fold um
considering the fact that the bill
speaks to liquor but I'm assuming that
that would apply to wine sales as well
because that's that's not quite in the
language but there were over 10 million
individual sales that occurred um in
fiscal year 2023 2022 and 2023 so
there's a significant amount
of manual stuffing of information
putting up posters um and we're not
really sure exactly what the information
it is that we're supposed to include on
a poster talks about Bill talks about um
resources and that was part of our
conversation with
representative do are you do you are you
pointing them to a certain agency are
you pointing them to a certain phone
number or website where where are you
pointing them and it wasn't really
clear what uh the sponsor want wanted
and I know there are more than one
sponsor now but really wasn't clear to
us what it is that they wanted us to
promote um and so that therefore um we
we think that this uh the concept
certainly the commission is engaged in
promoting Public Safety we have an
educational excellent educational
programs that we offer around the state
uh to lenses and civilians alike um the
enforcement and Licensing is dedicated
to making sure Public Safety is the
number one priority so we also
distribute posters dealing with
identification etc for lenses so we're
not unfamiliar with this type of process
uh but this seems a little bit vague to
us uh and especially where there's no
appropriation attached to it um you know
it would look it would appear to us that
the cost initially would be over $200
,000 just to print the trifold U
handouts and of course Distributing them
is going to slow down some of the
process uh especially possibly during
holidays Etc where we're uh employees
are going to have to continue to get
these materials put them into bags or uh
everything that goes out so we think
there are some significant challenges
that uh if the bill is going to move
forward that we think should be
addressed
thank you for take my question thank you
if we if a nonprofit um would come up
with a a poster with uh The Liquor
Commission and there was one poster in
each liquor store just giving people
information about where they can go if
they have you know alcoholic you know
issues if they're alcoholics or you know
uh Recovery Center um would that be
possible it would just be a poster that
we could probably produce with the lur
commission and a nonprofit that deals
with alcoholism would that be possible
we could probably amend this bill to
just get rid of the language of this
bill and maybe just introduce posters
and liquor stores well I I would need to
speak with uh chairman mik to see
exactly um what his feelings are about
that uh the commission does display a
lot of responsible uh Mater material now
and it stores certainly dealing with
underage drinking Etc and over service
so I think that um I'm really not in a
position to say yes but I think I I
would be happy to bring your request to
the chairman to see how he feels about
that okay thanks well in terms of
followup on that um obviously there was
200 to 450 and you just said that you
know the major cost is probably that
three the three-sided folded right color
glossy handout so did you do a breakdown
on your when you did your uh fiscal note
did how like I would assume if we just
put posters you know 110 posters
probably wouldn't cost us much money at
all compared I would think it's the
three-fold so so we we would save a lot
of you know well the the posters
themselves we talked to graphic services
and um they wereing us a figure of
800 uh I didn't see the back side would
that would because these would be posted
in our liquor stores so that's that's a
fairly insignificant amount of money
considering um it's the uh brochure and
the information included on the brochure
and in some cases um that may be if that
information is outdated or it needs to
be updated now you're we're talking
about a lot of information which um
would have to keep track of you even
though HHS is part of this equation um
they they're pretty much much
sanctioning our the message that's being
delivered as opposed to uh providing
what the content would
be thank
you yeah I would I would think that um I
mean I know we have we the big push now
is 988 for mental health services that
if we work with them in conjunction and
you know a poster but it's seem to me
you you really just can't stop it but
you almost have to have a little that
little holder in the front with a card
that you could take with a phone number
and with a contact information but it
still be a lot cheaper than trying to
put a something in every package well I
and um this is
probably I probably shouldn't suggest
this but as you know the commission is
is introducing its new uh computer
system uh very soon and a lot of the
information that's printed on the
receipts is programmable right so you go
that's a good idea too you could uh
thank you sir
um uh where you could
potentially print a a message that says
if you need help call this phone number
Etc um and now that's accomplished
automatically and it's a right then we
don't have to think about that it's
already on the receipt that's something
any other questions
for attorney more see none thank you
very
much is there anybody else would like to
so
so um this will is one of many that you
will see with my name on the bill but
frankly I have very little contact
whatsoever with what the intent of these
Department bills I would say that uh
whether it's liquor or banking or
Insurance um and you know in other years
it's been Securities and whatever when
when I bring in a a these bills are
Department bills so they are that this
is they're carrying the flag and uh um
but I'm more than willing to to put my
name on it to in that way making sure it
gets properly handled if nothing else so
good afternoon good afternoon
commissioner uh good afternoon for the
record my name is Amelia Galder and I'm
the bank so unfortunately these mics you
got to pull it and really turn it
towards me yeah it's like you're on
radio okay uh for the record my name is
Amelia Galder I'm the bank commissioner
for the State of New Hampshire with me
is general counsel for the banking
department saraki and in the audience we
also have uh the director of consumer
credit Michael pulos thank you uh for
the opportunity to provide testimony on
HB
1243 uh this bill was d uh drafted at
the request of the banking Department um
it revises RSA chapter
361a holistically um with a goal towards
modernizing it and streamlining it and
making it consistent with our other
statutes we do have a handout that I
think is going around that pretty much
covers what Seth and I are going to talk
about but we're just going to go over it
in high level detail and happy to answer
any questions that may come up RSA 361a
generally covers um Auto licenser and
regulation of auto financing by the
banking
Department this is um this has been an
ongoing effort at the banking Department
to to make all of our statutes read
nicely look similar contain similar
Provisions really to facilitate smooth
regulation of our licensed entities as
well as to provide sufficient consumer
protection uh one of the purposes of
this overarching rewrite was to um try
to get out ahead of some consumer
protection issues that we had been
seeing cropping up I'd say over the last
several years there's been a moderate
increase in consumer complaints filed
against um auto dealers who facilitate
financing um of auto trans uh sale
transactions and so we rewrote this
statute with a goal of trying to get out
ahead of some of those issues before
they become big issues um in that
process we did an initial draft and then
we ran it by the Auto Dealers
Association um and they provided us with
really helpful feedback and we were able
to work out a few a few tweaks that um
Seth is going to talk about that
hopefully we can work on as an amendment
to the bill as it stands now um so with
that I'm going to let Seth um talk about
some of the details of the bill and the
amendment
good good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee um I very briefly wanted
to touch on some of the specific changes
in this bill to RSA 361a uh first I
think most importantly this reinforces
and clarifies the banking Department's
exam mination authority over retail
sellers um going forward uh with the
passage of this bill the banking
department will include the retail
sellers in our regular examination cycle
so they'd be examined once every two
years um this is designed to ensure uh
retail seller compliance with New
Hampshire law um it also ensures regular
communication between the banking
department and Retail sellers so we
think this is good for both the business
Community as well as for consumers um
there's some some technical changes to
the uh changes to the bill uh or changes
to RSA 361a as well um there are some
additional annual reporting and filing
requirements which are designed to
achieve the same goals in terms of
regular communication between us and the
business Community um the the law will
now impose a net worth requirement on
all lenses of
$25,000 um there are some other
technical changes to clear up some
ambiguities that that we've encountered
in the law over the past years um which
have made it difficult for the banking
depart for for the businesses to follow
the law and for us to administer the law
and this bill is designed to clear those
up um as the commissioner mentioned um
we will also be offering an amendment um
to this this bill that um we worked on
over the past uh few months in
collaboration with the auto dealers um
the amendment that you will see is
really designed to do four things first
it would revise the effective date of
the bill current in the current version
uh the effective date is July 1st of
this year it would push it about six
months to or six months exactly to
January 1st of next year um both the
banking department and um the auto
dealers I think would benefit from that
six additional months to prepare for the
changes that are there um it the
amendment would modify the definition of
significant event um that exists in thew
law um under the law lenses would be
required to report what are called
significant events so for example a
significant lawsuit that impacts the the
lenses business and um as we worked on
this with the auto dealers the goal was
to strike the right balance between um
requiring lenses to report to us what we
think we need to know in order to
properly regulate them but also not
placing an unreasonable burden on on the
business Community um the next Amendment
will be to modify a section of the bill
that pertains to the initial license
term for lenses and that's basically a
technical change that is designed to
align
361a with our other laws that that
govern our other licenses and also
aligns with the system of record for uh
retail seller licenses the national
multi-state licensing system and finally
there are some technical sort of
clarifying changes to the examination
section um of the bill uh the banking
department and the auto dealers I think
spent the most time on that particular
section to ensure that businesses know
what to expect from our examination
process um and um and to to make to make
those changes clear um with that if I'd
be happy to answer any questions that
you
have
okay yes thank you Mr chairman
you you mentioned um considerable
consumer complaints is there any
anything in particular that that sort of
overwhelms all other complaints any
particular uh instances or or or that
sort of follow in a pattern
um trying to think so consumer
complaints are confidential so I have to
try carefully about what I say but
generally speaking I think what we were
seeing was a lot of educational
opportunities where if we had been able
to get out ahead of it and do an
examination we could have helped educate
the lensey to about what our law says
and they could have fixed the problem
before it became a big problem um for
example we have a component in our law
that requires pay off when you go and
trade in a car and get a new car um with
a loan they the um lender has to pay off
or the auto dealer has to pay off the
old loan within a certain amount of time
and some people just weren't aware of
that component of the law and if we had
been out there doing examinations we
probably could have gotten out ahead of
that and Ed done some education um but
we don't the way the law currently sits
we don't do those regular examinations
unless there's a big big problem that we
find out about through the Consumer
complaint process so we weren't able to
like know that that was such an issue um
so it's it was mostly like I'd say a lot
of Education driven issues thank you
very
much represent of
Ammon thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming and testifying um I just had two
two separate but related questions um
could you tell us about the penalty
portion of the law uh what's the worst
that can happen to a a dealer that is
out of compliance and then uh I'll ask a
followup if that's okay okay so
generally it's the I know that it's
nearly identical to our other laws um
maybe you can speak to that a little bit
more specifically yeah the the penalty
Provisions have been restructured to
align with our other laws but they
really haven't been changed I would say
some of the most severe penalties would
be a revocation of a license a bar from
being able to receive a license and
there could be uh potentially
significant monetary penalties um and
that depends on the number of violations
under the law um so those are the main
sorts of um in terms of the most severe
penalties that that's what I would
consider but again just to emphasize I
don't think that's changing we just
changed the way it's written to make it
more clear and so if somebody's looking
at the penalty Provisions they go oh
this looks just like the penalty
Provisions in RSA 997a okay yeah but
over the years um we have instituted
restitution and that that you have have
the ability to order restitution yes
that's not changing we have all the same
Authority that we do under current law
but and just a quick followup for the
question inquir uh so separate topic um
the the
proportionality of the compliance burden
and I'm thinking of the largest auto
dealer group versus the smallest Auto
Deal group uh does it advantage or
disadvantage one size outfit over
another um Michael and the audience can
probably come up and speak to this
better than I can but I'll give it a go
um so we um tailor our exams to the size
of the entity to the size and complexity
of the entity so you've got a big big
entity that does lots of business we
might assign two examiners to it do it
in x amount of time if you got a mom and
pop shop that's done just a handful of
loans we're going to maybe do a one-day
exam or a desk review of that um we also
have the ability to accept exams from
other states and do multi-state exams um
in terms of the auto dealers who just do
the retail who just have a retail seller
license most they're they're not
licensed in every state so that's a
little tricky for doing a multi-state
but for the big sales finance companies
like Toyota finance they're licensed in
50 states so lots of times we can take
advantage of doing a multi-state exam or
accepting other states examinations so
we try to tailor it to the size and
entity very much thank you
okay
Dan um good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Dan
Bennett with the Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association we're a trade group for the
motor vehicle industry about 500
businesses uh car truck motorcycle
snowmobile ATV construction and farm
equipment both franchised and
independent uh in all Corners in most
communities of the state so uh we're
here today um on hb1 1243 to say uh we
support it uh with the amendment um that
was just spoken to we've done a lot of
work um with the banking Department uh
we'd like to thank and um appreciate
them for the hard work that went into it
um attorneys on both sides had a lot of
back and forth uh we think we came up
with an amendment that is um that is
positive that's that's business friendly
um we support the need for the banking
Department to do the
modernization um it really does set the
bar and also level the playing field uh
so we think that there's some positive
things to to come from the amendment um
and so as mentioned um we support both
the 35-page bill and the two and a half
submitted
any questions from committee members see
none thank you very much thank you sir
is there anyone else would like to
speak so uh since we have a a little bit
of time here I I'm going to use this as
an opportunity to tell a story and that
is
um story time yeah story time because I
got time so so at any rate uh imagine
how long ago this was uh Kelly a aot was
the Attorney General all
right and the issue at the time was the
who is exempt from the consumer
protection act now we had you know
Brendan Ganon was in here today you know
talking about the consumer protection
act and in the consumer protection act
we have um we had several exemptions uh
and we visit we have visited this issue
multiple times over the years uh I would
say the good news is we don't have any
bills this year here to revisit it again
but we have because some people don't
like some of the exemptions and in those
exemptions um is we have four which is
the Public Utilities Commission the bank
Department the insurance department and
the Securities division uh what occurred
was that uh we had a little incident
with an auto dealer who uh argued that
they were exempt from the consumer
protection act because they had uh BR
they were the banking department they
had they were registered uh to do
financing and they had a little
parchment on the wall that says that
they're a licy and so they thought that
they could get license out out of it um
it was quite a struggle and uh but we we
were able to stick in the consumer so if
you ever look at the consumer protection
act and under the exemption you'll see
the last sentence says except auto
dealers who are have this
license to to the
financing uh and so the reason why I
think it's important for everyone to
understand is is that
um what we ended up doing in that
consumer was uh to get to solve the
whole thing of the exemptions to the
consumer protection act was the power
restitution and that is that the banking
Department insurance department were did
at the time did not have it and we were
able to give it to them was that they
can make a consumer whole if a
consumer's been harmed then make them
whole whole and so yes in the same case
with this with the an auto auto dealer
if there was a problem with the
financing obviously if it's something
related to the car or those other things
there's a separate statute related to
all that but more importantly that is
that um these four exemptions done under
the consumer protection act um all three
all of them have what the consumer
protection act has which is the power of
which power of restitution and so they
made the consumer whole and so I I'm I'm
just saying this because I think in
terms of globally trying to understand
um what we did because we have all these
bills and related to you know Brendon
was here and we related to the consumer
protection Division and what its job and
what its mission is which is to is that
power restitute is to make you the
consumer make the New Hampshire consumer
whole from the from whatever happened
whatever in terms of the transaction but
this is something that's been on the
books in a while and it's worked really
well and uh and uh I think that we have
a
great situation in terms of how we
understand the where where where the
consumer protection act begins and ends
so that was my five minute
story all right uh so we have another 10
minutes and then we're back to
liquor
you know we haven't had any sign in
sheets well I picked one up earlier I I
yesterday no no you oh very important if
you want to get paid you got to do the
machine
downstairs so this this sheet here
actually never leaves the committee room
oh okay and it's really it is uh it's
supposed to so that you could if people
want wanted to see whether you were here
today in the committee room then you
know you could have signed in and and
never showed up to the committee room so
but that's true I didn't I haven't
signed that I don't think Le well that's
right yesterday wouldn't be the first
commissioner and he's gone
what
just
me
did
I
been
got
oh
d
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
House Bill 1227 and here from the prime
sponsor representative Jessica Grill
welcome to the Commerce
Committee thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you to The Honorable members of
the committee um as the title suggests
HB 1227 extends the time that alcoholic
beverages can be served on site from 1:
to 2:00 a.m. Statewide and it also
enables cities and towns to authorize a
3: a.m. limit if they so choose this
bill will give bars restaurants and
event venues more freedom to serve their
customers expand nightlife opportunities
and encourage people to patronize New
Hampshire businesses currently we have
one of the earliest Statewide closing
times in the country most States set a 2
a last call including many states of the
in the Northeast like Vermont and
Massachusetts and allowing
municipalities to approve a 2A on last
call in 2013 was a step in the right
direction however there have been no
changes to the law
since hb1 1227 will align our liquor
laws more closely with our neighbors and
will make our state more competitive for
example someone might be more likely to
choose New Hampshire as their
destination for a corporate retreat over
Massachusetts or Vermont with more young
people looking to build their careers
here and tourism being such a large part
of our economy it's past time to take
another look at closing
time another benefit of this bill is
local control many of our cities and
towns including burlin nasua and lonia
have already opted to set their last
call at 2: a.m. under current law giving
them the option of a 3:00 a.m. last call
will give them more flexibility a city
could enact an ordinance authorizing a
3:00 a.m last call for special events
like New Year's Eve or the 4th of July
much like how lonia currently allows
alcohol to be served until 2: a.m.
during Bike Week
to address some public safety concerns
I'd first like to speak to the issue of
drunk driving when the RSA was last
updated customers had far fewer options
for a safe ride home than they do now as
ride sharing Services have grown and
state agencies have invested in
educational campaigns New Hampshire saw
a 13.9% decrease in drunk driving deaths
per capita from 2010 to 2019 um I also
want to call out that while we did
unfortunately see drunk driving increase
in 2020 and 2021 um this was during a
period where bars and restaurants were
either closed or had um very limited
service which indicates that there are
other factors at play besides Bar and
Restaurant closing time while you may
also be worried about potential
increases in overall crime a 2017 study
showed that increased foot traffic is
linked to lower crime rates although
correlation does not equal colation and
we've seen other study results are mixed
this suggests that residents and
visitors are more engaged with their
communities when commercial activity is
present additionally allowing bars to
serve drinks later is not a permission
slip for unsafe and illegal Behavior
vendors can and should still be held
responsible for over serving their
customers serving alcohol to miners or
allowing other unsafe behavior on their
premises we must continue to empower our
local police to enforce the laws and
keep our community safe essentially this
bill is about Choice it will expand
Commerce for businesses Statewide while
giving cities more options to meet the
needs of their residents whether that
means keeping last call at 2: a.m.
extending it to 3:00 a.m. um or doing so
on a permanent or temporary
basis if a business owner doesn't want
to stay open that late they won't be
required to just as they can close
earlier than 1: a.m. now HB 1227 simply
puts more control over closing time
where it belongs in the hands of local
communities and the businesses that
serve them thank you I'm happy to take
any
questions okay I guess that's pretty
straightforward bill
represent
bilio thank you for taking my question
have you talked with um um bartenders
about this
Bill yes I have and in general they're
all in favor um from the ones I've
spoken to um obviously limited sample
size I um haven't been able to survey
every bartender in the state but the
ones I talk to are excited about the
opportunities for um more revenue for
their businesses more more tips frankly
and
um helping increase that foot traffic
that that brings in money just a
followup so if there's a bartender that
really can't you know work until 3 but
the restaurant
owner wants the restaurant to be opened
up at 3 uh it might cause some issues
with some employees maybe maybe not I
don't know I I definitely think that's a
valid point and um that's an issue
that's not uncommon in the restaurant
industry I think scheduling conflicts
are always going to be an issue there's
people who prefer to work the night
shift there's people who absolutely
can't work the night shift um this bill
doesn't address any of those concerns I
um so I I unfortunately can't speak to
the specifics there but I would
encourage um you know bartenders who are
concerned to speak with their managers
and and try to work out a schedule
that's better fit for their their own
needs representative pusc thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for taking my
question has the restaurant or
Hospitality Association been contacted
about this
B I see he's got his b card in his
pocket um I have not had a chance to
speak with them yet but it looks like
they're
here any other questions
to okay get off
easy
re thank you Mr chairman thank you thank
you representative grill for taking the
question um did you do you have any data
on do drunk driving increase after a
certain hour of the evening you know
like likelihood of drunk driving deaths
or injuries or whatever after 2 am. or
whatever I uh did some research through
the um New Hampshire Department of
Transportation unfortunately I wasn't
able to find any time specific data for
New Hampshire um I've seen studies
Nationwide and those have seen mixed
results um some other states and other
countries as well have seen increased in
increased drunk driving um incidents
late at night some have seen decreases
um so it was unfortunately impossible to
to draw a clear conclusion of the
relationship between the
two okay everybody else
said okay thank you very much is this
person
stay he was making a p fast joke so it's
good now you can turn your mic on turn
hit the button oh we're on okay how
about that um appreciate the opportunity
to speak today um so uh my name is
Michael Strand I am a Bedford Town
counselor I manage a small business in
Bedford and I am a dad I guess would be
the qualifiers um so I think this bill
is really common sense in my opinion and
I'll explain why um admittedly um you
know I'm not going to admit my age here
but as somebody with a 10-year-old I
don't get to spend a ton of time out at
bars or engaged in the best of what
Manchester Portsmith you know nightlife
has to offer um but I do know plenty of
people who work in the service industry
um I am speaking in favor of this bill
as well um so I did myself for years
work in the service industry sometimes
as a second job often as a first job
um and you know I'll tell you that along
with
um you know the the bill yesterday that
I could only submit written testimony
for and I hope you read it I think this
is a common sense um prob business a
political bipartisan bill um you know we
all work or did at some point in our
lives right um so my question uh to this
committee would be what's an hour worth
um when we talk about extending um you
know sales of of alcohol um you know
more importantly what's an hour worth
when your hourly wage is plus or minus
five bucks an hour you rely over 90% on
your tip-based sales revenue of which
your employer takes none because they
got 100% of the gross margin on your
sales minus wages um and more
importantly you know you're a
bartender so you know I think you know
serving the highest demand product since
the beginning of time uh in the only
privatized direct service retail setting
where you can capitalize the sale of
that product without government
government intervention um is a is a
relevant thing to talk about or think
about um you know in short you sell
liquor beer um you know and in the only
place you're allowed to sell it and get
TI for your services so I think when we
have these broader conversations about
you know the role of government from a
macro standpoint or the impact on
business and individuals uh we we kind
of live in a funny state sometimes U
don't
we you know we're talking about the last
hour you know last call uh the final two
rounds you know when responsible best
practices uh you know with regards to
avoiding you know over serving or
employed um but this is the best time to
sell your product it's the best time to
make money um you know pay your bills
support your family and you know live
free without having to die for it um
Live Free or I is kind of our funny way
of framing policy in many cases um and
it's a turn of phrase capable
encompassing uh all manner of evil or
you know in this case I think good U
this is about the freedom to work in my
opinion um if the concern is Public
Safety I'd have to try not to laugh to
be honest with you um you know I
actually pulled some um you know
ancillary data regarding differences
between DUI charges death rates per you
know uh capita um and match them I'm
you
oh okay I apologize um so um you know
there's actually no uh identifiable
correlation between states that close it
to and and higher rates of alcohol
related crime uh from a first glance um
you know I'd encourage you to do a deep
dive but um you know particularly in
this state you know we're a small State
uh we have a great law enforcement
community and I think we do tend to
respect each other's rights and act
pretty responsibly I don't view that as
a you know any increased you know public
safety hazard um but I don't even think
we should have to talk about that really
um because you know having a
conversation about whether we should
regulate you know cutof times it's going
to defer to the the choice of the
business owner anyhow um and really to
zoom out for a second the government
pre-regulated businesses or individuals
you know commercial rights out a
speculative assumption regarding
individual New Hampshire citizens
behavior is just not a winning formula
um it's like regulating pre- crime you
know I wouldn't do it um I would even
potentially make the argument that to
not
put this bill on the floor with an not
to pass you know could amount to however
unintentional you know legal
discrimination against the whole class
of workers in the granite state you know
inhibiting their ability to do business
support their families um so to me this
is an easy one um I'm happy to take any
questions but I think uh you know it's
apolitical and it's an easy move to
deregulate and help business and and
people u i just ironically that the
argument was the when we changed it to
one it was 11 and that it that was the
argument of why we needed to go to one
was to give the person who had the
second shift interesting I guess now
you're going farther out you're now deep
into I didn't I didn't realize it was 11
that's that's pretty pretty
crazy thanks for taking my question this
is more of a would you believe um I live
in Bartlett which is a more rural
community and we do not have um ride
services like Lyft and Uber so would you
believe I do appreciate the fact that
you're leaving this to local control
because I have a real concern about
people not having a ride um we have more
moose and deer at that hour than we do
people but um I I also want to protect
the wildlife so I appreciate that it's
local control
sure well I want to protect people too I
don't say
that okay
repr thank you Mr chairman Mr strand did
you say that you don't believe there's
any correlation between uh
more accidents from DUI and would you
believe that the prime sponsor testified
to the contrary just before he walked in
the door uh no I did not realize that um
again I I just took a a rough
correlative glance at you know different
states and what the rates were who had
you know on average higher you know
later uh you know times that they served
so I just you know again I frame that
argument in the fact that I don't
believe we should need it because I
think you know that's an overstep I mean
I mean you know what individuals choose
to do um you know whether right or wrong
that's a separate criminal issue it's a
separate legal issue and um you know I I
don't know that this body or we have the
purview you know to to legislate based
on what could happen again it's
legislating pre- crime which I
fundamentally have a little bit of a
slope yes represent
we deal with a lot of liquor bills and
um
the if an individual is in the
restaurant or in the bar in the
restaurant and they're there until 3 o'
in the morning um do you think they're
going to be drinking more because they
have one more hour or less or yeah I I
think it that's where you're going to
get a high level of variability across
uh you know across different businesses
you know based on policy Best Practices
I mean there's pretty stringent guidance
on you know not over serving which I've
you know I don't have a ton of
experience you know seeing this but I
know at least in our area um you know
restaurant owners and folks who are
concerned about their own level of
exposure or liability are are pretty you
know pretty attentive to this and I
don't know that it'd be 3:00 a.m. um but
um you know I think typically you know
if you extend it to two you know you
would have things winding down long
before two I don't think people would be
there until three um I think you know
also individual Common Sense people who
work in the industry have had plenty of
experiences good good bad and ugly and
they are going to be proactive in terms
of making their own lives safer and
easier as well so um you know I tend to
trust uh individual business
prerogatives here and individual
people all right thank you
yeah okay so uh Before I Let You Go and
um that I've been around here long time
I was here when we change it from 11 to
one and we did have the discussion at
that time about leaving it up to
different towns and letting them and the
reason why that didn't make it was the
concern
that um it would it spot it would be
call spot zoning spot so that if one
town say really out of they don't they
don't want anybody drinking driving
through their town after a certain hour
sure but this other town next door does
pass it and they're upset that now
everybody's driving back and forth and
yeah and consu if they had if they had
consumed too much then it creates a
hazard to that to their community and
that's why we ended up not doing that
last
time right the neigh so I think that's a
fair concern you know particularly when
we talk about one community's ability to
to negatively impact or infringe upon
the rights of another you know assuming
we go back to a local control model um
but I mean I think you can see this sort
of nuance local legislation you know
both in the state and nationally even
when you go back to uh coming out of
prohibition years and Which counties and
towns were dry and what time you know
they could sell retail obviously in New
Hampshire it's different because you
know the state runs um you know retail
liquor store uh excuse me ret retail
liquor sales through the stores but um
you know we're also making assumptions
here that you know and yes people make
mistakes and drink and drive and often
pay the price and unfortunately do hurt
other people sometimes but um people
shouldn't be drinking and driving period
so to you know to try and you know
curtail uh you know rights in one regard
you know to prevent other crimes from
happening and we could we could run that
experiment up and down government and
have quadruple the laws that we have and
I just I don't think that's the answer I
people shouldn't be drinking and driving
period they shouldn't have two in drive
you know they should make reasonable
accommodations they should have a friend
who we mandate that there' be a
designated driver I don't know how you'd
enforce it talk about inexpedient to you
pull over and there isn't one then
they're going to get bust for sure well
you know and I'll say this living in a
community that is very much uh you know
historically was you know a Crossroads
you know to the state and certainly is
now if you ever drive down 101 um you
know I also tend to trust call me naive
but I trust law enforcement you know I
think they get a lot of these folks who
are not following the law and when you
combine that uh you know pretty strong
guardrail which is there for a reason
you know in existing laws around
consumption from public intoxication to
you know driving well under the
influence you combine that very broad
governmental broad guard rail which I
think is effective both in terms of uh
catching those who do it and you know
being a clear signal that prevents
people from making the wrong choice and
you combine that with good common sense
so people don't want to kill themselves
or others and they have friends who
might be willing to you know to start
drinking water for the last two hours or
whatever the case may be or not drink at
all um I don't think that there's a need
to to change sales related business
policies as a result of fear over this
okay thank you very
much okay thanks for your time okay I
have two cards left and we have
enforcement and Deputy enforcer are we
doing it separately or are we
up so Mike are you to testify or you
say I used to give Jim demur a hard time
when he would do that to me all the time
okay uh thank you Mr chairman and uh
honorable committee members again uh for
the record my name is uh Mark armaganian
I'm the chief enforcement and Licensing
for the Liquor Commission also with me
here today is Deputy Chief Danielle ston
um and and we will probably pull at uh
Danielle's previous job being uh field
commander for uh the field area so uh
what the way we look at this uh first of
all I I think the
representatives uh for what they what
they have put together uh as a proposed
bill at the same time I think there's
uh we're looking at this from an
industry stamp point and I think we need
to look at this from a safety standpoint
and and a law enforcement standpoint
also uh you brought up a very good point
uh Mr chairman um this is going to be
looked up as all of you know and most of
you know that have been here a while um
six and a half years ago when this
Administration got together in
enforcement we only regulate to the
level of community and Industry Safety
we believe that there should be local
control and and this issue specifically
has local control attached to it and
Danielle will be able to speak more
about how only three jurisdictions in
this whole state have actually pulled
out that availability that you mentioned
Mr chairman um this uh in speaking to uh
the Chiefs even if we if we take um
let's take let's say we take Hillsboro
County uh because most of the sponsors
are from the Hillsboro County area we're
looking at 32 municipalities in that
area out of that two two-ish cities
maybe three depending on how they're
established um and we have an unfunded
ma mandate once you create longevity
with ours of service enforcement has to
be out longer you have the unintended
consequence of the jurisdictions that
don't want this to happen they have to
put resources on the road and I feel
that this is a um a burden that's going
to be put on the taxpayer at the end of
the day which I we've always been
looking at this as saving resources we
have an industry that stop that shuts
down at 1:00 drinks off the table by
1:30 um if they extend
service um through either their
municipality or through us uh we're
looking at an extra hour on that so we
know what the stop is I know how long
that we have to create
coverage um and and I I would hope at
some point but good people make mistakes
as as was stated um you know that
everybody acts appropriately and service
is done appropriately and it doesn't
always happen that way that's reality
and that's why we exist so uh with that
in mind I I'd like to give U the floor
to Danielle to to speak further on this
good afternoon um so I think it's
important just to point out the law as
it is right now the law right now allows
lenses to sell till 1 patrons can
consume their alcohol till
1:30 um there is the provision in the
law that allows the local municipalities
to extend the service till 2 which
allows patrons to drink until 2:30 only
three municipalities in the state have
done that um as stated by the the
sponsor Berlin lonia and nasua Kia's
provision is limited to the were's Beach
area Nash's provision is Li is limited
to only those licenses that also hold
tradable gaming licenses so we don't see
this as a significant push throughout
the state to move the the hour until
2:00 um and like the chief said the
there's also a provision that allows
lenses if there is a specific event
where they wish to extend their hours
they can do that through the commission
and the commission can grant that
exception we actually have a significant
amount of lenses that do this during New
Year's Eve they request to to extend
their hours of service for that that day
or for a particular event so that
provision is Al also already in the
that as I mentioned earlier I think also
that um and I know Beth was here earlier
uh the chiefs of police uh specifically
the one of the largest jurisdictions
being the Queen City Manchester
um the chief would actually be here
saying stating the same thing that we
are it's just it puts a burden on
resources that um would actually have to
be relayed to the
taxpayer it's more people more people on
the street more police officers on the
street more enforcement investigators to
actually make sure that our mission
keeping this industry and the community
safe um is is adhered
questions do you um
knowing in each Community where which
establishment is going to take advantage
of this do you then stick around all the
time to that closing hour and we do
after hours checks to make sure that
they're closed so maybe maybe there
should be an added fee maybe we should
you know have a license to stay open
later and uh to to offset our state cost
to have enforcement
there um that as as always uh we remain
neutral on these suggestions uh that are
brought up by this committee um but uh
one thing I did want to mention is in
that in that jurisdictional area the
county let's say of Hillsboro we have
330 I'm sorry sorry
530 lenses in that county through those
jurisdictions um I couldn't tell you
what the number of uh not only
traditional law enforcement but uh
liquor investigators there would be to
actually um have oversight of of this uh
because know that when people are are
letting out of these establishments they
find other EST establishments to go to
like breakfast
establishments and and places that don't
sell alcohol so this um this extension
of hours will now go into the Wii
morning uh the Wii uh hours of the
morning uh we're we're looking at if if
it's 3 o' with drinks off the table at
3:30 we're looking at 4:30 possibly 5:00
and now we're 24-hour coverage so we're
coming here for more manpower and going
to fiscal it's
it's it I like the the idea uh for
Commerce but the negative outweighs the
positive in our view in our
view
okay you guys one more point one more
Point um as we run into now with the
current lot as as it is we would ask if
this does move forward that there is a
requirement for the local jurisdiction
to notify us that they have extended the
hours um that hasn't been the case in
the past so we usually find out through
the newspaper or or walking into the
establishment so say If This Were to
move forward we would request a at least
a notification to us so we were aware
that that municipality has extended
their
hours okay yep we do have another
question represen just quick question uh
so the current statute as as it stands
it says the license he may sell until 2
a.m. under conditions authorized by the
legisl by I think I just answer my own
question so the legislative body locally
can put conditions you mentioned where's
beach only or cor uh betting casinos uh
in Nashville only correct that would be
you okay we're all set thank you uh
Sebastian
bill who do you who do you I see you
have an orange
bag put put the yeah my apologies uh
good afternoon gentlemen uh my name is
Sebastian Fuentes I'm the political
director for rights and democracy of New
Hampshire uh I'm not here representing
them right now I just want to I saw the
the bill and the the importance of the
bill and I just felt like a little bit
of my work experience might be able to
uh might be give a good uh I can give
you good feedback uh I work for 18 years
in the hospitality industry in the food
and beverage uh I was a director uh
Director of Events C banquet captain at
the omnimon Washington hotel up in Bon
Woods uh also at the mountain bu Grand
in Whitefield New Hampshire doing
Banquets events for about 18 years 18 19
years almost so all I want to say is uh
I discussed this bill with a few of my
current uh friends that are still
working in the business and what they
asked me to to to kind of present to you
is like the a few of them especially in
the management world that they really
agree with the the concept of this bill
because they want to make sure that they
increase the sales now with that said
excuse me uh there's a lot of ongoing
already training going on in this in
these premises uh I was team trained
certified for I think 12 years to be
able to provide the best the best uh you
know um management of the alcohol sales
to to our patrons uh another another
common occurrence that happened to us
while working at the hotel uh especially
doing weddings uh when because we end so
early many of our uh the clients the
guests will go somewhere else to find
alcohol so what this bill maybe
implicitly try to help us is to be able
to uh keep all those folks in one place
to be able to monitor it better uh we
have a lot of instances where they go
off site they go drinking on their own
and that's when uh a lot of the those
issues with the uh local law enforcement
happen uh uh it happened to me many
times in different in both of those
properties and uh it is it is really
important that we also take in
consideration that these places uh put a
lot of effort into training uh I'm just
speaking for those two properties I'm
pretty sure that happens all around the
state but um they they would like to to
to be able to you guys consider this
bill for uh to be able to keep more
businesses to keep business in New
Hampshire because a lot of those uh
guests uh that come out of the state
they look at our legal laws and says hey
you guys are closing too early uh we're
not going to come here uh it happen many
times too so I just want to kind of uh
see if you have any questions I know the
percentage bu you ask about if you know
if you talk to our bartender I have
myself and and a few of them are in
support of this bill because you will
increase their you know the amount of
money that they bring home because they
want to make money you know serving
alcohol is is definitely how they do it
but the time they want to do it in a
responsible way they'll be able to put
uh our our guests the clients the peders
are safe while also bring some money to
to their home so I just want to kind of
uh if you have any questions I'll be
more than happy to hopefully uh some of
the experience I have in that field uh
might be able to representative buroughs
thanks for taking my question um you
mentioned that you know you had you
worked in Whitefield and yes spret and
woods and patrons may go somewhere else
I I just looked there are no bars in
Whitefield that are open after 8:00 p.m.
and um I don't know of any bars in
Breton Woods that might be open after 1:
p.m. I mean there's just nowhere to
go my apologies there there are bars
opening Whitefield later than that uh uh
we have a view in the common area of
Whitefield uh they just they just brand
new you might not have it on your list
but there's some in there uh a bon Woods
what happens is many of those guests
they come they know they're staying for
a couple days so they bring their own
alcohol with them and they they do they
go to the rooms right and they just you
know they they just stay there longer
than expected and and but it's hard for
for uh us employees to monitor what's
happening in those rooms you know it's
not really we're not going to knock on
the doors every single time say what are
you drinking or you know there under AG
people drinking on those rooms that's
something really that uh is extremely
hard for us but we you know by doing it
maybe by passing this bill and extending
the hours of service might be able to
contain him in uh in the banquet venue
we may be able to have you know the BART
chanders the barbs and everybody else is
working including the captain and
management to be able to watch them uh
more closely and keep an eye on them
thank you so what time does the Omni
close now the the Omni close yeah I've
been out of that business for about two
and a half years now I don't know if
they Chang times but when I was there
you know last call usually they have an
underground bar uh ends po 30 the cave
yeah we all been in the Cave the Cave uh
and then uh 12 30 last call 1:00 drinks
of the bar uh and that was still fairly
early so they could take advantage the
current law and extend it but they
they've never gone to the town and and
Brent Woods and ask him to get that
extra hour I I think that's you know
that's kind of like just internal
management you know uh it's kind of like
a corporation as well you know so they
they run things differently a it venture
to wonder is maybe you how about the the
uh the Whitefield the uh what it the
Grand View right Mountain View
gring so what time do they close uh the
same same hours for events and I'm just
talking about the events the rest there
could be a possibility that these people
are pretty happy closing when they're
closing now and they don't really want
that extra time uh I can say for
experience that that wasn't the case
many times uh they they always want to
extend the hours they also wants to uh
you know they they feel like because in
other states in the around us uh is a
little later that they feel that they
can do it later uh when when in reality
that's not the case in New Hampshire we
have to for Force what the laws are uh
right but the law says they could stay
open till 2:30 right but that's just
they haven't chose so I'm just I'm
playing Devil's Advocate with you I'm
saying is Gee the law already allows
them to stay open later why would we
need to pass this when they're not even
willing to take the hour the law that we
already have on the books then maybe
maybe they really don't want to stay
open later maybe they really don't want
to keep their employees around longer
maybe they're that that you know that
seems seem to me that we did find the
right spot given that that's what time
they're willing to close at right now I
think they'll be I mean I I would love
to have uh the team the management team
from any of those properties to come in
and testify or not to be honest when you
see them urge them to send us letters we
won't be taking action on this Mill in a
couple of weeks so uh you know flood our
mailboxes with interet or Internet
mailboxes with telling us to convince
that that there's a great demand for
this you can all visit the North country
and stay at those beautiful hotels as
well I stay I stay at the nain Inn yes
and I'm very upset with the Omni because
they won't serve me dinner because I'm
not staying at the hotel oh wow so I
love to be able to stay there but they
won't let me stay there for dinner but
um I have been to the cave and I would
say that those big hotels would be the
ones who you would make sense to be open
to stay up later and that's why I'm kind
of shocked that they haven't taken
advantage of the current law I think
that's based on every special you know
every client is different you know every
client decides how long they're going to
serve and you know that's just the
specifics of each of each client okay
thank you very much thank you chairman
Mike and I would say you're going to be
the last card but Amanda's put her card
in so she's going to respond to whatever
you
say do I dare okay so I was going to
hold my remarks until the work session
as this committee loves to do work
sessions but I guess I'll jump in now um
just for P for recognition so my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association we have about 1300
restaurants hotels and other attractions
Etc as members from all over the state
um uh my experience in the industry
directly was not as long as the previous
speaker I was only in the industry about
15 years but I worked everything from a
dishwasher to the general manager so
I've tended bar I've waited tables I've
done all of it certainly been there and
done that that um normally I would be up
here testifying in wholehearted support
for something like this as it's less of
a restriction on businesses but um after
speaking with our board and our uh
membership we did kind of a straw poll
survey uh last week and not knowing
where everyone would be um we kind of
came out with somewhat of an unofficial
position we won't adopt it till next
week but uh at this point it looks like
we're about 60 to 40 opposed to this
bill um I suspect and again looking at
the the businesses that respond fed um
the late night drinking places where
Hospitality employees love to frequent
uh very supportive of this um but then
many restaurants hotels and other
actually weren't which kind of surprised
me a little bit and I think to your
comments a moment ago Mr chairman I
think a lot of these hotels Clos down
because more than anything staffing
issues they don't want to stay home with
any later because they can't they can't
cover
it um I will also uh I do want to Echo
the last U person who testified these
comments on training I think our
industry DS uh uh an an exceptional job
in training again it's not 100% but it's
a it's it's a pretty high bar uh many of
these businesses invest a lot of time
effort and resources making sure that
their stabs are trained appropriately
visible signs of intoxication what
constitutes over service those kinds of
things so I just want to make sure we
put that on the record um but I I think
that this is a rather complicated issue
for the industry and it really gets down
to it's it's not just about it's an
extra hour it's more sales because it's
much more than that under some of the
lies that these businesses carry they're
required to have food available while
these alcohols are being served so then
that's not just a couple of bartenders
it's you got to have at least one person
in the kitchen that person has to be
Serv safe trained because of the person
in charge rule under the food safety
rules you have to have the the the
equipment turned on you have to have the
hood system running so this it becomes
ancillary costs that are attached to
that and one of the ancillary costs that
I think we often forget in these
discussions is liability insurance which
comes up more often than uh than we care
to admit but I think that U right now
there is some flexibility in the system
where municipalities can already adopt
the 2 a.m. I don't know that 3:00 a.m.
is is a necessity uh for for New
Hampshire but um certainly open to the
discussion when we get to a um to work
session um and I think the other one
that's worth noting too in some of these
more builtup areas where you might
actually find ride shares there becomes
a staff safety issue about you know
folks walking out of a bar with a pocket
full of cash at you know 2 3 4:00 in the
morning so um that certainly was
mentioned but I will say that in our
straw pole survey the number one comment
that we got back from all the members
Oppo opposed to this was nothing good
happens after midnight so I'm sure we've
all used that phrase I know I've
certainly heard it um and I would also
just uh Echo a comment from
representative burrow about ride share
you know ride share might work in
Manchester it works in Boston and other
major municipalities it doesn't work
anywhere outside of those kinds of areas
unless you have have a significant rural
buildup there really are no ride shares
so the later you go I think to uh
representative Moo's uh comments earlier
I think that you do uh raise the risk
and hence the uh increase the liability
insurance exposure for these businesses
um with that I will stop save it for the
next work session and happy to try to
answer any
questions thank you very
much good that's great thank you
say it's been a minute since I've
testified on anything um I just came to
watch but thought I'd make a couple of
points I'm Amanda Balden uh rep from
Manchester W five um there's um when it
comes to selling more alcohol more food
late at night there's more meals or
rooms tax coming with that um so it's
not like the expense of enforcement just
goes up in a vacuum um there's benefit
to the additional late night sales also
um you know just did a little Google and
it looks like um only like less than 10
states in the country don't have a 2 am
last call the vast majority do Alaska
has a 5: a.m. last call I don't know
that's because of how little sunlight
they get maybe they have like a 6 PM
last call at other parts of the year I
have no idea but um and interestingly
Vermont has a 2 am last call and has
fewer drunk driving deaths than New
Hampshire and I think it's worth noting
you know that it is since none of us are
data scientists it probably would be
extraordinarily difficult to draw any
links between any one policy and the
other but it certainly seems Pro
business and and pro worker and um Pro
Commerce that's the name of this
committee right to uh pass this
legislation so um just I think those
were the only points that I thought
might be helpful to interject into the
conversation is that um Vermont has
better hours and fewer drunk driving
deaths than we do and um something like
30% fewer and uh and that when you sell
more booze I assume that's on a per
capita basis um because they're much
smaller State than we are no it's
uh no I think that's um just the bare
numbers yeah okay but it's per capit
less yeah I I didn't really feel like
getting out a calculator and putting all
those zeros in um but uh but you can
Google it too um but then the other the
other point being um that there is a
benefit to um the economy in New
Hampshire when people can engage in
Commerce for longer periods of time
thank you I don't want a question
question we have questions
representative M I know it's we're at
the end of our day here thank you for
coming and testifying if your question
is am I going to go to a BS no I'd stay
at home oh
no I could make a joke on what you just
said but I won't um so would you believe
uh that this uh legislation could be
considered anti-discriminatory uh and
the reason is because people have
different chronotypes so chronotype is
when you're most most alert when your
circadium rhythm is most alert and there
are night owls we've all heard of night
owls and there are morning Larks people
who get up early in the morning and
there are I think finches are people
that are midday active and I think that
this Society discriminates against the
night ow
because representative Ammon I would
believe that that's a terrible argument
but I also want to know what which one
tracks there might be a real question
yes representative
migu thank you Mr chairman um it's kind
of a clarification so this is something
I've been keenly aware of since you know
working the streets as a medic picking
up enough drunk drivers and things would
would you believe that Vermont is the
fourth worst in the country for drunk
driving deaths no and that's the per cap
you mean on a per capita basis it's
interesting they the fourth worst is the
rankings and um by per capita and um on
the bare numbers and I didn't see that
all of the above they're also 600 and
change, imagine the distance from one
bar to another in that state you know
could be 2hour drive so yeah it's
imagine
that imagine that so they're one of the
worst in the country I think if the
committee wants to put effort into
trying to draw delineations between
different sets of Statistics it's worth
worth your time but it would take a lot
of time because I don't think that it's
easy to just draw conclusions based on a
limited set of information I think it's
really complicated if it wasn't
complicated we wouldn't be sitting here
someone else would do this someone who
gets paid a decent
amount not 100 bucks a year maybe they'd
be getting like 120k and they'd be
really smart and they'd figure it out so
well you get the perks like I got you
know I think I'm getting 20 bucks in
mileage today so
so repres CL yes thank you um allowing
me to ask a question um so
uh is this mandatory for every
restaurant that they have to be open
till 3 o'clock in the morning or can
they make those choices for themselves
that's not my read of the uh legislation
I'm confident that it is uh up to the
individual business there's definitely
places I I wish I could visit that
aren't open as late as I'd like thank
you
it's uh I would say I have a wide
selection of liquor at any time you can
have but no some towns do just you
know they're the the operators in the
town and I think it's the employment
problem they just don't you know the
people who are the bartenders are are
not college students even though we have
a we have a University in rench but um
they they um they just they close up at
10 is it not the case that there is a
bartender co-sponsoring this bill do I
understand that
correctly two bartenders co-sponsoring
this bill which says so much about the
legislature in New Hampshire but also
about this bill right yeah different
things
so okay we all said everybody all said
we had we had our Giggles okay thank you
very much all right with that we will
close the public
hearing and
tomorrow